testing testing one two three
this is your one minute testing
careful
yeah
yes
um
foreign
okay I apologize for the delay in our
start this morning but we're
numerous members are having travel
difficulties today so
that's the reason for our late start
but it is now time to start so I welcome
everybody to the January 24th meeting of
the science technology and energy
committee and as usual we'll begin this
morning
by all rising and joining representative
Kat McGee as she leads us in the Pledge
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
foreign
day weather-wise here in the state and
it's affected numerous members of this
committee
I know that representative Harrington
will not be joining us today because
he's had some significant electrical
problems at his house caused by
power surges
representative lewicki indicated that he
was having trouble getting out of his
town due to closed roads
and I see a lot of other Empty Chairs
here so
that's indicative of the fact that the
weather has caused us significant issues
one of this and give significant issues
it caused was it forced us to cancel
yesterday's activity which included
um
presentations and Bill hearings
the bills that we were supposed to hear
Yesterday would have been the subject of
an executive session today
but since we did not hear those bills
yesterday today's executive session
will be
either canceled or postponed I have to
and what we've done to make up for the
loss of yesterday is we've added another
so I regret to inform the members of the
committee that you're going to have a
very busy week next week we're going to
be meeting on Monday
Tuesday
and Friday
and there is a house session on Thursday
therefore you're going to be in Concord
a lot next week sorry to say
but we have to do it because we have to
get caught up we have 39 bills and we
need to get them all through executive
session by the 7th of March
so today we'll be hearing
or having public hearings on three Bills
starting at 10 30 this morning
but before we get there
we're going to have a presentation about
the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire
and I'm pleased to welcome the honorable
Clifton below to make this presentation
Mr below is one of the most
knowledgeable
persons in our state about energy
matters
having a member been a member of the
general court both in the house and the
Senate have having served on the Public
Utilities Commission
for the past 25 or almost 30 years now
Mr Bulow has been involved deeply in New
Hampshire energy issues
so there's no better person I think to
make this presentation than the
honorable Clifton below so Cliff it's
all yours and welcome to sdne thank you
representative good morning everyone
thanks for making the trip today
um
let me start with some Basics and then
I'm going to go into some background and
kind of bring us up to date
um
so
um just the basics what is community
power and it's uh
provision in the law that allows New
Hampshire cities towns and counties to
become alternative default service
electricity providers for their
residents and businesses and provide
related service services so the basic
idea is that
Municipal aggregation also known as
can pool uh purchasing power to buy
electricity Supply meaning the
generation that puts power into the grid
to match what consumers take out the
utility company still delivers the power
and provides grid reliability and the
community can benefit from value-added
services and programs and uh
expectation of lower rates and more
product choices it's RSA 53e
relative to the aggregation of electric
customers by municipalities and counties
that enables this
um a couple of the key points is that
customers may always switch back or opt
out in the first instance and stay on
the utility default Service Supply or
take service from a competitive supplier
Community power programs must be paid
for out of revenues received by
participating customers it can't come
from any taxpayer subsidy
one of our member communities the town
of Durham came up with this graphic to
kind of explain the basics as they were
developing electrical aggregation plan
it sort of starts with the uh governing
body of the community select board or
city council creating and electric
aggregation committee
often it's their existing energy
committee and they draft an electric
aggregation plan that has to be approved
by the Public Utilities Commission
um and then it uh goes to the Town
Council in Durham's case which is their
legislative body as well as their
governing body or town meeting
um in in a town with town meeting so the
legislative body has to prove the
electric aggregation plan
um points
the governing body appoints the
representatives to the community power
Coalition if they're joining the
coalition
and overseas Durham Community power
um
Durham has uh part of the group that has
helped create and govern the community
power Coalition alongside other member
communities the Coalition will serve as
the supplier for Durham it has a
community appointed board and committees
expert staff and vendors and provides
power and services on behalf of each
Community power program that's that's a
member of it
um the utility will continue to deliver
the power provide metering and
Consolidated billing and of course ISO
New England operates the Interstate
even
excuse me representative once has a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in just a question on your
previous Slide the um the approval by
the puc does that is it a requirement
that that happens before the plan is
submitted to the um the Town Council or
the town meeting or is it can it happen
whenever
it can happen either way
um it can be submitted in advance of the
legislative body approval of course then
they would have to approve it as the
commission approved it or can be
submitted afterwards mostly these have
been submitted after uh the legislative
bodies approved the plan quick follow-up
follow-up
um so if it if it gets submitted to the
puc afterwards and the puc makes a
change does it then have to go back to
the the governing body for for
reapproval they did do that with some of
the first plans
um for instance
um our our city submitted a plan
um roughly a year ago and um they hadn't
completed the rulemaking process so they
uh uh rejected it essentially they had a
couple of issues and we went back and
amended the plan to address the issues
and kind of waited till the rules were
far enough along that they could be
comfortable that it would be consistent
with the rules
thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
yes
thank you Mr chairman and again thanks
for being here today sure
so if
if I understand correctly
every community that wants to
participate in um
take advantage of community power has to
submit its own electric aggregation plan
to the puc yes what would distinguish
one communities what might distinguish
one community's electric aggregation
plan from another what are the what are
the major features of the of an electric
aggregation plan
um
we'll get into that a little later on
but um I I would say that
um
that often they reflect
um tied into it as any policies or goals
that a local community has adopted and
the plan May reflect different emphasis
on those uh there are a couple different
approaches one is is the Coalition
approach another approach is to engage a
broker
um to put the loadout to bid so there's
a couple of different models for how to
do this so some communities have adopted
plans that go one way or the other and a
few communities have adopted a plan that
allows a future Choice as to whether
they go with the with the broker model
uh the chair has a question sure so my
assumption is that the the community
power Coalition they would serve de
facto as the energy portion of the uh of
the residents uh electric bill correct
yes
okay uh thank you and so as a quick
follow-up on their electric bill it
would show Community power aggregation
or yeah it we haven't quite finalized
that with the utilities whether it'll
just say community power or Durham or uh
Hudson community power whatever
Community it is
um or I don't think it's going to say
community power Coalition it might just
say community power but
um that that's a detail that we're still
sort of working on
okay thank you by the way I can email
these slides because I realize the the
printout it's a little hard to uh read
if you want to follow up so I can do
that if you'd like
um I I want to run through some
background and context to sort of bring
us where we
you know our and and sort of from my
point of view how Community power has
come about
um but it also provides a little bit of
history as to how
um electric utility policies have
evolved in this state and I'll just
start I'm going to try to run through
this fairly quickly
um but this could be you know a whole uh
a course uh
you know just if we look at the electric
power industry started
um in the late 1800s
um it was very distributed it was on
Municipal by Municipal basis started
primarily in industrial centers or where
there was hydropower
um so we had lots of little uh systems
that over time got Consolidated and over
time there was a basically a
century-long trend towards economies of
scale bigger was better uh Power
Generation became much much more
economic at a larger scale so there was
this tendency to get larger generation
and in fact some of the smaller old
hydras were discontinued over the course
of the 50s and 60s as this was occurring
um we saw the first major energy price
shock with the 7374 air Oil Embargo at
that time a lot of electric generation
was from oil including in New England
um you know part of the reaction to that
was a movement to go ahead head with the
Seabrook Nuclear Station which began in
1976 in 1977 this legislature enacted
the New Hampshire limited electrical
producers act RSA 362 a
which was enacted a full year before
purpa and if if you look at you know if
you perpa and the Lipa act were
basically based on the same model a
policy model which said independent
power producers also known eventually as
small power producers or qualified
facilities under purple could sell their
generation to the Monopoly utility if
they could sell it at or below the
utilities avoided cost and the utility
had to contract with them for that power
um that's significant because several
things happened over the next decade
um in May 1979 Governor Hugh Allen who
was elected on running on anti-quip
which is uh against allowing
construction work in progress to be in
the rate base which was about secret
Seabrook that was put into law
and at the same time the cost of sleep
work of rising and there was this
initiative by some of the smaller hydros
to restart those and a larger wood to
energy power plants that sought
long-term contracts with eversource that
were based on seabrook's avoided cost
projections that kind of kept growing to
justify continued investment which it
had to do because there was a period of
high inflation and the interest on the
money they borrowed to build the plant
they couldn't recover from rates so they
had to kind of justify a continued
investment by projecting that future
costs would be high and that's what
those contracts were based on on in 84
you unit 2 was canceled
PSNH went through a three or four year
bankruptcy process Northeast Utilities
acquired them and part of that deal was
for seven years of five and a half
percent annual rate increases which
ended up leading us to the uh as a state
the average highest rates in the whole
country even higher than Alaska and
Hawaii which was exceptional at the time
um and so what that led to I was first
elected to this committee exactly 30
years ago I was sitting in our seats as
a freshman legislator and in my first
term one of the bills that got
introduced um one of the big issues was
the above market cost for these small
power producers and I was appointed to a
study committee that and PSNH
renegotiations legislative oversight
committee and the purpose of that was to
try to
um encourage uh PSNH was arguing that
part of their high cost problem was
these independent power producer
contracts and they wanted to renegotiate
them because at that point by 94 they
were way over market and projected to
continue to be way over market and um
and and so you know we started thinking
about how do we unwind these or or kind
of uh address this problem that led in
95 to the creation of a retail willing
and restructuring study committee and at
that time this concept of retail willing
was just sort of a new idea that was
being talked about a lot could you have
more competition and just sort of a
context to this is part of what purpa
did drive because it allowed code
generation with some innovation in
getting higher efficiencies from
combined heat and power generation and
there was also deregulation going on in
the natural gas side which ended up
driving combined cycle natural gas
generation which was sort of a new thing
in in the in the in the 90s uh which
which was to say you could kind of
double the efficiency of burning natural
gas by having two cycles a turbine like
a jet engine that drives a a a turbine
to make electricity and then you also
make Steam from the heat that's left
over so you had two cycle combined cycle
and you've doubled the efficiency from
the 25 to 33 range to roughly double
that
um so that this this was sort of
happening in industries were saying in
many areas not just New Hampshire hey we
could buy one of these uh combined heat
and power plants and um and produce our
own electricity cheaper than we're
buying it from from eversource so you
know let give us a break
um out of that study committee became
our re electric utility restructuring
act
um which was enacted in 1996 it went
there was a whole lot of work that went
into it and a very broad bipartisan
consensus was developed
um in the legislature at the time it
passed basically almost unanimously
through the House and Senate
um and it was a new paradigm it said
let's make it's sort of recognized that
we had screwed up at several levels the
the utility had screwed up by over
investing arguably they built we're
building a single project fifty percent
over a thousand megawatts which was
going to more than double their entire
generation capacity in one project and
that you know the cost went from a
billion dollars to 6.6 billion dollars
and that was billion dollars for two
units to 6.6 billion for one unit
um and so that was sort of a uh a
monopoly mistake and then Regulators
then legislators kind of compounded that
by creating a law that linked these
independent power producers to that
price and cost and then Regulators all
encourage this to go on in until sort of
the the House of Cards sort of collapsed
and the bankruptcy occurred and we found
ourselves trying to figure out how do we
do things differently so that
legislators regulators and the Monopoly
don't make this kind of mistake in the
future and part of the answer was we
could move you know generation no longer
had to be a monopoly that you could have
a choice of generation and there could
be a competitive wholesale market for
generation and there could be customer
Joyce choice of the generation Supply
but let's keep the wires vertically
integrated
um I mean a monopoly because it only
makes sense to have one set of wires let
me interrupt you just a second
representative Thomas Doug Thomas has a
question yes thank you Mr chair going
back to your previous statement um I'm
just curious you said that they
recognized that the the power company at
the time had overbuilt
given today's situation do you feel that
they still overbuilt or are we on a
different
line of what maybe should have happened
I'm just curious if if maybe they were
before their time or not
um
it's hard to say I mean it it's it the
history is is what it is
um I
I I think
the the idea of the time in the 60s was
that each of the major investor in
utilities New England would sponsor a
nuclear project and then others would
buy shares of it this was sort of at the
extreme end of that PSNH was a
standalone company in New Hampshire
alone their total demand was only about
a thousand megawatts and they owned
something less than that in generation
and they were kind of doubling that and
they were rejecting a huge amount of
growth in electricity consumption
um roughly you know projecting a
doubling now we have gotten there you
know over several decades but it wasn't
there there's just a whole combination
of things High inflation High interest
rates
um that and and and and natural gas
prices coming down from the deregulation
and natural gas that made natural gas
very competitive with this Capital
intensive project
and and quite honestly the uh uh the
federal Regulators you know said this is
a case study in red tape that that
Seabrook was mired in it
um Three Mile Island happened in the
middle of this and they kind of redid a
whole bunch of things that added to the
cost it's it's a whole complex case
study that
um I I don't want to try to speculate
um but what's interesting about this is
that in parallel with this house
committee passing over to the Senate the
restructuring Statute in the same
crossover the Senate sent to the house a
bill to create chapter RSA 53e
aggregation of electric customers by
municipalities and counties now the
interesting thing is Jeb Bradley was the
chair of the committee at the time and
the bill came over allowing the
possibility to do this on an opt-out
basis Jeb thought that we this was a New
Concept nobody else had done it
um so he he sort of said let's do this
on an opt-in-only basis initially enable
it and that's how we uh this committee
unanimously amended the bill and um
basically it's that dormant for the next
20 years so um that but I'll kind of
catch up with this in a moment
um so at that same time like a month
later after we passed and the New
Hampshire house was the first
legislative State legislative body to
pass this kind of restructuring Bill uh
to saying let's spin off generation into
a competitive market
um
so for I should order 888 and that was
you know we knew that was in development
and the title that case was promoting
wholesale competition through Open
Access non-discriminatory transmission
services and it was a reformulation of
the federal role in power regulation and
said let's move towards transmission
systems that are open access because
they had been what were called pancake
rates like you you you you paid for uh
pass passing through each different
section of the transmission system and
they sort of said let's do this more
like a postage stamp rate and have an
open access tariff where any supplier
and any consumer any uh load serving
entity has access to this competitive
wholesale market and that's where ISO
New England Nepal sort of evolved uh um
spun off part of its role in the iso New
England became a regional transmission
organization an independent system
operator that's sort of where that came
out of uh for that fork order 888
and we were very you know engaged at
that time in looking at what that meant
and the implications of it and how our
legislation fit with that
um subsequent to that I worked with with
Jeb in the committee on a leap of Reform
to an end the obligation of utilities
under state law to buy it took some
years before uh for got around to
changing uh ferc in the same way so he
said no longer uh did the utilities have
to buy from these small power producers
that avoided costs
um they can you know sell through the uh
wholesale Market if they want
um uh but we also created net metering
as part of that same legislation that
particular Bill uh went through eight 18
work sessions
um and and uh it was Gemini who had
sponsored that uh keeping it all very
bipartisan
um and created net metering as an
alternative under under the leap of
Statute
[Music]
um
in two thoughts just jump way ahead
um 2017 or 2016 metering uh was expanded
from the initial caps when we first
enacted it we were thinking of it more
as primarily for early adopters we tried
to enable the notion of limited
producers able also being able to sell
independently of net metered but that
never really got taken advantage of
um uh but that called for the puc to
look at developing new uh tariffs um to
sort of update the original a formula
from from 1998. so in 2017 the puc
issued an order after a long proceeding
to approve all new alternative metering
tariffs sometimes called net metering
2.0 at that time I was representing the
city of Lebanon and we proposed a pilot
of what could be considered a
transactive energy framework where the
customer generator could both buy and
sell at real-time prices reflecting the
wholesale market and get credit for
actual avoided transmission and capacity
cost using the RSA 53e Municipal
aggregation statute on an opt-in only
basis and
um but as in the in Liberty worked with
us on that the commission ordered
Liberty to try to work with us to make
that pilot work we ran into multiple
obstacles including some provisions of
53e that were catch-22s like we had to
do a mailing to all customers but a
subsequent law said that utility
couldn't give us the names and addresses
of customers unless we got their
individual permission so we couldn't
comply with the law so that that
leads us to the last bit of background
um which was an initiative in 2019 to
update the statute to offer opt out
alternative default service and expand
some of the authorities and straighten
out the glitches in the law now that
Bill happened to be co-sponsored by Jeb
Bradley who you know 25 years earlier
had
um argued it should be opt-in only but
he was persuaded that opt-out made sense
at this point it had never been used
other states had done it only on an
opt-out basis so we started an
organizing group that resulted in the
Coalition in late 2019 at the same time
uh uh rule making stakeholder groups at
the puc started and the first draft of
rules were ready by late 2020 and we'd
also developed our joint Powers
agreement I'll explain that in a minute
um but in 2021 House Bill 315 was
introduced representative Oz was the
sponsor and but it had been drafted by
you know eversource
um and it it in some ways sought to
straighten out some issues in 53 but in
other ways we felt it sort of you know
tried to undo the progress we had just
made a couple years early or and had all
sorts of problems this committee
understood those and um there's a lot of
public engagement and uh representative
Vos
um this was in in the middle of the
pandemic but he encouraged us to work
with the utilities to find compromise
and helped facilitate a very intensive
four or five day everyday meetings that
were virtual so it was it was time
efficient but we eventually worked with
other stakeholders with utilities with
members of the committee and came up
with a compromise that was supported
broadly by by essentially everyone and I
think you know it it um in a lot of ways
it did improve the statute provided much
clearer consumer protection uh uh
Clarity on some of the authorities and
the roles
um and created the requirement for puc
EAP review and also created the
possibility of a purchase of receivables
program
so but then in July of 2021 the doe was
created the POC was reorganized so sort
of this sort of languished for a bit
until late 2021 we and the doe
petitioned for rulemaking with working
off of the rules that had been developed
a couple years earlier and then
um after the Senate Bill 315 was enacted
you know looking at how the rules need
to change there
so um that resulted in a final proposal
by the puc in Late July of last year the
city of lebanon's electric aggregation
uh
plan was the first approved in August of
last year oh says 2023 that's 2022.
um and jailcar approved the rules in
September and there was a final option
adoption by the puc in late
October
or early October
so um what is the community power
Coalition we're Community uh governed
power supplier uh looking to launch
community power programs hopefully in
April
um we were created as a non-profit joint
power agency in on October 1st of 2021
um I kind of forgot I don't really have
slides on this but we're we're organized
pursuant to RSA 53a which is a law that
is about
um enabling uh subdivisions the state to
work
um uh to
work collaboratively by sharing
authorities legislatively granted
authorities to exercise those jointly
including through creation of a separate
entity in this case we're called what's
called a governmental instrumentality
we're separate non-profit Corporation
under New Hampshire law but we are an
instrument of our Municipal members and
County member and and so we've we've we
are not a subdivision of the state but
we are governmental instrumentality
subject to RSA 91a the right to know law
so we're you know our meetings are
considered public meetings
um we have 27 members at present almost
about double from one when we were
originally Incorporated represent and
another one in the next week we'll join
um representing about 21 percent of New
Hampshire's population at this point
potentially these are default service
only customers including sort of some
attrition we assume some may not want to
come over but it would be about 125 000
customers over a million megawatt hours
per year on the order of
140 million dollars a year in revenues
um and there's about 12 communities that
are aiming to launch this spring and
more next year and that sort of
just turn myself off on a button so um
how did this come about well it it is we
spent three years on trying to adapt
National best practices for a joint
power agency in a lot of ways it's
modeled on the Public Power experience
there's over 2 000 Municipal Electric
Systems in the country they often
operate they operate the distribution
system usually on a Town by Town basis
or city some big cities like Austin and
Sacramento uh Jacksonville Florida or
our Municipal systems but a lot of them
are smaller and so a lot of them over
the past 50 or 60 years joined together
to create joint power agencies
um to do things like uh uh do joint
generation projects or to procure power
in competitive markets and so the map
sort of shows some of those that exist
so in a lot of ways our joint power
model is based on that it's designed for
robust Democratic governance and
oversight economies of scale
risk management of a portfolio power
supply contracts Advanced retail
customer services it's a proven model
for new project development and local
programs to be supported by a team of
professional staff and advisors uh of
which there's a whole industry
um maybe I won't repeat all this but um
there's some more detail on some of the
local policy goals that we hope to
achieve
um including for basic products lower
cost uh options
um as well as opt-out projects for
higher renewable content or clean energy
content we hope to be involved in local
project development uh working in
collaboration with utilities on local
infrastructure issues particularly
bringing back Community scale solar and
storage we'd like to help provide
commercial Innovation particularly to
smaller businesses there's been a lot of
competition for larger businesses and a
fair amount of innovation but there's a
lot more that can be done and also
building equity and economic development
in our Energy System
[Music]
um
this there's a lot of words here
um uh
the design context here and what I've
done is I pulled the slides for that we
have for multiple uses
um and and so that a little bit is more
detailed and redundant than perhaps
necessary but um they were what was at
hand
um there there are basically two models
uh contract with a for-profit supplier
by using a broker uh that puts the load
out to bid there's some uh advantages to
that so it's relatively simple it's it's
um widely used in States like
Massachusetts another model is to create
a community-owned supplier like uh
Public Power agencies have done co-ops
have also done this uh in a lot of areas
Although our Co-op provides all their
own Services in-house mostly
um and uh and there's some advantages to
that not the least of which I think is
demystifying how the power sector works
and creating more uh understanding and
informed decision making that will
support Innovation over time I mean the
well we we have all of our board members
have been sort of
um like you a little bit overwhelmed at
times in terms of understanding the
complexity of our electric power system
and everything that goes into it
um but also feeling like they're getting
a better understanding of what works and
wasn't what doesn't work
um because sometimes there's there's a
tendency to sort of suggest simplistic
Solutions when
the solutions are really pretty
complicated
um so where does it exist the green
states are where uh Community Choice has
existed for a period of time uh some of
those dates of when states have been
enabled it it says New Hampshire 2019
because that was the update of awe in
fact New Hampshire's law was the first
it just sat dormant for a long time the
Massachusetts Market all the sort of
colored communities are ones that either
this is from a couple years ago either
had
Municipal aggregation or I think the
blue ones might be ones who were in
process of of doing that they've had
some relative they get race stability
usually two to three year contract they
usually have some moderate savings
they're usually able to add somewhat
more renewable content there's minimum a
minimum amount of in Innovation and um
and and limited public advocacy uh there
is and this is a little bit more about
the broker it's fairly simple stay steps
there's three active brokers in
Massachusetts
two of which colonial power and good
energy have partnered with new
hampshire-based
um uh
Brokers or aggregators a freedom energy
Logistics with colonial power standard
power with good energy that are
basically offering this same model in
New Hampshire
and there's that some communities have
signed up with them the Massachusetts
compact model was something of an
exception they were actually the first
Municipal aggregation and it was uh um
1997 and it was 21 towns on Cape Cod
Martha's Vineyard who sort of joined
together to create a joint power entity
like our joint power agency pursuant to
laws that enable that like our laws um
joint exercise of powers
um and and there is some value there's
some things that they have done that are
different and unique
um part of that was because they were
early on in restructuring and kind of
captured the operation of the Energy
Efficiency programs on the cape if I
could interrupt for a second
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question when there's a broker
I assume the broker takes some sort of
cut of what's going on can you give us
some some sense as to what that would be
um I used to have that number on the top
of my head but I don't right now it's
it's on the order of a tenth of a cent
it's yeah it's on that order
um it might be
a couple well yeah it's on the order of
a tenth of a cent
[Music]
um
representative muns would like to ask
sure thanks Mr chairman
um if a community creates their own uh
aggregation plan and and you know
initially decides that they want to go
on going on their own yes
how difficult is it for them if they
then want to join the join your
Coalition and and then as a follow-up
What what is the what is the procedure
that they would have to go through I
mean what what do you have any kind of
vetting standards well um
they have to execute the joint Powers
agreement so they have to kind of come
in with the terms that have already been
established
[Music]
um
they um
but you know the only caveats the board
has to approve admit them as a member
which we've done with everybody who
wants to join so far
um
uh I mean typically uh the experience in
Massachusetts has been they usually come
up with two or three contracts and that
that has worked well particularly in
this period because a lot of these were
started before the recent run up in
prices this particular slide has a
couple of hyperlinks that also detail
um situations where the retail supplier
because they were aggregations were
depending on a single supplier uh went
bankrupt because they didn't you know
weren't sufficiently hedged for the
market conditions and uh programs have
had to shut down as a result of that and
in Massachusetts in some cases a year
number of years back they went into
three you know some went into three year
contracts and two or in the second or
third year out the market prices came
down the default utility default service
came down and uh you know customers
migrated back to the utility default
service so they had to shut down the
program so it kind of so the point would
be after that contract Runs Out somebody
could consider training transitioning to
the coalition
follow-up
thank you of the 27 members in the
Coalition now are there any that
um
that initially created their own plan
and have now decided to join the
coalition
um I Peterborough was sort of like that
they they kind of um forged their own
way they kind of did a hybrid plan based
on ours and Keen which was with standard
power and good energy and uh and then
they decided to do this fall sort of uh
request for proposals and we responded
to that along with at least one of the
Brokers
um and they ended up deciding to go with
us
um so they kind of had their feet in
both camps for a while
thank you
and nashua's plan is also written to
provide those options but their energy
committee is or electric aggregation
committee has recently recommended to
the board aldermen that they proceed
with the Coalition they've been a member
of the Coalition since the start so this
is just a slide that illustrates some of
the joint power agencies of course this
has taken off the most in California I'm
just going to share a little bit of that
real quick
um oops I'm going the wrong direction
page down not up whoa okay
um sorry about that
get way back there real quick somehow I
went to the end of the slides okay I'm
going to try to speed up some of these
um okay here so um in California ccas
have uh expanded a lot in in over the
past decade
um California is a sort of weird thing
they started with customer choice they
had a big problem
um from a legislative mistake they they
un froze the supply costs but they froze
the retail rate and didn't that didn't
work
um and so they shut down customer Choice
except for large cni customers but then
they reintroduced it with Community
Choice aggregation in which customers
can choose between the aggregation and
the utility default service and large
customers can go to third-party
suppliers but not small customers so
we're a little bit different from that
it's too small to see but the picture on
the right there just shows details a
bunch of projects that uh the ccas in
California have been developing and this
is just sort of a summary of the impact
of course the scale of California is
much larger than the scale that we're at
although we are at approximately at the
scales of one of the couple of the small
opening over 6 000 megawatts of new
solar thousand megawatts of wind uh 2.6
megawatts it's 2.6 000 megawatts of new
energy storage as well some geothermal
and biogas they're doing this through a
variety of means uh some of you know
some of them have received investment
grade ratings so they're direct project
developers although most of them are uh
through Power purchase agreements
um just to comment on this is a little
bit dated now but looked at over like a
a 10 or 11 year period
the performance of all the 50 states the
ones on the left hand side of the
spectrum with the black bars are
investor owned are vertically integrated
uh States they don't have any form of
customer choice the Green Line shows
states with customer choice and
competitive power supply markets and at
that point in time all the other states
that had that approach were doing better
in terms of the annual year over year uh
or the change in prices over this period
of time New Hampshire was right on on
the margin there
um so we felt that there's you know ways
to do oops I'll still pause here
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you very much Mr chair
um I'm just going back to that other
slide but you don't have to go back to
it okay um just the reference to
geothermal in California
um
in New Hampshire we're a Granite State
so geothermal can be difficult in
California there are an earthquake state
so does that
impact him obviously it's going to
impact you have some kind of a cap on
geothermal or anything like that
no you do not okay no I I mean there's
no geothermal electric production in the
Northeast that I'm aware of there's a
few somewhat hot spots but I they
haven't been proven out is viable
um
so
um what if we has happened over the
first year of operation
um and we're not operational still in
startup phase so none of these programs
have actually started yet
um but we've held over 110 public
meetings of our uh because we're driven
by volunteers and a handful of some
Municipal staff members who've been
involved
um uh but you know you know we're we and
and we've had a couple of Consultants
um uh we did raise you know roughly 150
000 in Grants and donations to help us
through our first year uh but um you
know we've we've been focusing on the
rules development
um and then in the spring we did a
full-blown request for proposals to
solicit all the range of services that
we need to launch
um with uh vendors who are willing to
work on an at-risk basis meaning we're
not going to pay them until the program
becomes operational so that our success
or their success or them getting paid is
dependent on our success and fortunately
uh because I think of a fair really
compelling case we got some really good
responses on our RFP and over the summer
we worked on evaluating those and so
we've executed uh contracts that were
negotiated over the course of the Fall
to give us the full capabilities of a
competitive electric power supplier
um to uh to stand up a joint power
agency and provide these services
including securing 750
000 and startup funds and eight and a
half million dollars in credit support
were actually in the process of kind of
concluding the arrangement uh with a
contractor lse that provides additional
credit support we've adopted a bunch of
major policies that have taken a lot of
work uh energy portfolio risk management
retail rates and financial reserves
policies and a data privacy and security
policy as well as conflict of interest
policy we've adopted cost sharing
agreement and member services contract
for complete service bundle which will
you know operate which is sort of our
initial product offering there may be
more things in the future and then we
also simulated our performance and
financial stability under 13 different
scenarios uh using stochastic modeling
uh which means you run multiple 100
scenarios with different assumptions
about weather economic conditions and so
forth and they confirm that um uh that
we are are very viable and and to the
best of our knowledge are almost
certainly this is the first such entity
that's launched using this very
sophisticated
um uh robust stochastic modeling
approach usually people just do a a
projected result and maybe a high case
in a low case we did 100 cases and 13
variations off those cases
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman could you talk a little
bit more about the stress test and and
what your what you're testing for
yes I think there'll be a few more
slides on that yep okay I can wait
um so we've had this fairly rapid
membership growth
um this is a bar showing the top of the
dashed lines on the right or the current
default service load of the four
different utilities
other than the few number of small munis
um and our current membership if they
were all the launch would Place us as
the second largest default service
provider uh the interested communities
that have expressed interest in possibly
joining uh would if they all joined and
um uh uh we would potentially be the
largest default service supplier in the
state
um just going to run through some of our
governance
um we're governing four communities by
communities
um interesting point we have a former uh
eversource executive as our vice chair
Kevin charette was
um early in his career with eversource
23 years based in Connecticut he was in
charge of their audit functions but then
he rose to become in charge of all their
customer service functions and so he was
really helpful in evaluating the
customer services proposal on our RFP
and more recently uh uh Brentwood has
joined us and the former director of
distributed energy resources for
eversource Richard lebreck has also
joined our board of directors so that
that's kind of interesting
um he only retired from eversource a
year or two ago
um
and and so we've really benefited from a
really interesting diversity of talent
uh from from across our members uh some
retirees uh some professionals just just
really uh valuable contributions
um we've engaged um expert contractors
who are the who are the top of their
fields
um Ascend analytics for energy hedging
planning portfolio risk management
Calpine Energy solutions for retail
customer service and uh providing a
contract load serving entity clean
energy New Hampshire is helping with
member services and public engagement uh
we've had a law firmer of Duncan
Weinberg ginser and Pembroke as our
general counsel they were originally
selected through competitive RFQ process
when we were first working on developing
our jpa and a couple of startup
consultants and also a specialized bank
that specializes in what's called
multi-party lock box which provides
additional credit support and we're now
in the process of working with true
search to identify and hire our first
staff person a full-time CEO with
additional staff in the future this is
just sort of an orc shock we're
accountable to our communities the
governing bodies appoint the board
member representatives to constitute the
board of directors we've had a number of
operational committees we have a few
more to stand up
um and it's you know until we have a CEO
I'm sort of in the middle of it as the
board chair I really look forward to
getting a CEO on board because this role
has become a full-time volunteer job
um uh but you know we have the power
agency operations and it eventually will
um and so we have a lot of people
working to help make this happen I am
not going to go into this slide but it
does provide a breakdown into some of
the detail cells of the kind of services
that we are both contracted for the
black text and the blue text as things
that we hope to achieve over the course
of time
the technical assessment
um uh on the lower left you can see
um I hope you know that's the hundred
different scenarios with probably the
blue line in the middle representing
What's called the p50 probability case
um uh you know it's sort of the midpoint
of of the modeling and that is showing
up the the build up the cash reserves
over time and you'll see a seasonal dip
with winners because you know part of
this in standing this up is to create a
financial reserves so that we can you
know you have to use that to stabilize
prices through the winter when costs are
highest but also to provide stability
and unexpected events
um there there's a whole lot to this
technical analysis but and uh but but
essentially and this has already been
updated once so we're about to release a
revised version of this because this was
done back in December
[Music]
but the the bottom line is it shows that
we seem to have a business model that's
going to be quite viable
um oops wrong direction
um I'm not sure I show all the stress
tests that were done but basically we
did about 14 scenarios I'm not sure I
put all those slides in here off of that
um but this serves a shows a breakdown
of what the revenue uh picture would
look like
um the vast majority the Orange is the
or yellow is the energy cost
um for the project there's capacity cost
um in the wholesale Market RPS
compliance costs some other things uh
operating costs very small
um are deferred compensation uh
for startup cost works out to less than
1 100 of one percent so that's uh not
one tenth of a sentence
um one uh
to that's just 0.01 percent of Revenue
is 0.02 percent of revenues it's it's a
small number
um and so you know we happen to be in a
situation where prices have actually
dropped rather dramatically since
December so the utilities have walked in
relatively High rates so you'll see that
the first period uh potentially March or
April April really through through July
the green bar show there's there's a lot
of Headroom even if we offer a discount
and and um we haven't decided what the
discount is off of the utility rate but
but it'll be significant and uh there's
an opportunity to build up some reserves
because market prices are so much lower
but that also puts us subject to
competition retail customers are finding
that they can now get private contracts
uh that that beat the default service
rate as well so we'll be operating in a
competitive environment that provides a
certain amount of fiscal discipline
um local project context the inflation
reduction act provides a lot of
increased incentives which can be
monetizable by municipalities and
non-profits so there's a lot of
opportunity uh particularly there's a
bill that came through this committee
last year Senate Bill 321 which enabled
some Pilots
um that still and process the POC
looking at the
jurisdictional issues but potentially
that is is a big benefit there are
adders for Brownfield sites or projects
that benefit low-income communities in
terms of the monetizable tax credits
um and uh the the the the the some of
that picture shows some of these areas
uh where there's additional incentives
available for various reasons
um just a quick overview of the process
for Community to launch the excellent
Coalition agreements authorized
procurement select rates and launch
that's sort of the step that the wave
one communities are in right now uh the
steps that we've been through
um most recently eight communities have
so far approved the cost sharing
agreement the complete service bundle
and all the policies that we need to get
going and we're and we're working to to
make that happen
um we're about to launch public
engagement campaigns for the different
Community power programs these are some
of the logos that have been developed
the enabling agreements the kind of work
with each other
um our energy portfolio risk management
policy retail rates policy financial
reserve policies sort of create create a
a setup a framework to to manage this
prudently and that flows into cost share
carrying agreement and in the member
services contract so that this is sort
of equity herbal and durable based on
best practices from all the other
experience I'm just going to race
through some reference slides to
acquaint with you with those and then we
I can pause and have any questions that
you might have
um our startup team this is a theme
that's been with us for over a year now
um uh clean energy New Hampshire is
providing some specific limited Services
under a contract uh River City Bank has
this specialized structure uh that that
we're about to go live with the energy
risk management team from Ascend
analytics
um
and that what they do they offer really
state-of-the-art portfolio risk
management software oops and we'll be
using
um uh several of these products
um their portfolio uh uh Power portfolio
manager as well as their spark bidding
and scheduling software and eventually
the power planner software is to help
evaluate potential projects
um and of course they do Market you know
Intelligence on a view of the New
England Market their their software
incorporates a detailed view of the
Dynamics of the market I I won't go into
detail on this but
um it is it's it's it's it's an approach
that is
um uh
really pretty much state of the art
which is what attracted them to us and
um uh
uh uh and what and they were attracted
to the model that we've created here
with the legislative and Regulatory
structure
um if you go to their website you'll see
the broad range of entities that
contract for their services including
ISO New England and a lot of utilities
um Calpine is the predominant provider
they felt launch over 20 CPA joint power
agencies like the Coalition in
California serving over 4 million uh
customers
um have a dedicated call center of all
U.S based employees it happens to be an
IBEW Union shop but they specialize in
the community power model so that
they'll be uh people who who are good
customer support people
um they you know do provide the EDI
transactions and so forth there's
there's more detail on the kind of
services they'll be providing here
value-added data services ultimately
they've helped do recurve analytics
planner and a demand Flex Market which
is to say uh in the California ISO
context and there's some of this in New
England although we're still I have a
lot of opportunity here where you can
harness a lot of distributed energy
resources both storage generation and
demand response to help lower the peak
demand at critical times
um so that that's part of what they do
and I'm just going to conclude with a
few slides that sort of illustrate the
challenge in New England
that we have
um
and this is a slide from a storage study
from a few years back in in
Massachusetts but what it illustrates
this is a a one-year period with the ups
and down of uh the power hourly demand
um and you can see the summer The
Summer's in the middle of that
um and the peak hits that red line and
that's the peak demand and so the entire
Energy System transmission distribution
and generation has to be sized to meet
that uh Peak Demand with the safety
margin
um and most of the cost in the whole
Electric System are these fixed asset
costs it's it's it's not the fuel to run
generation it's the capacity to meet
Peak demand
um so a key Dynamic that has been
occurring over time in New England
um is is a shift in What's called the
load duration curve it's also can be
called an asset utilization rate this is
taking all the hours of a given year in
New Hampshire you're inserting them from
the highest hours of demand to the
lowest hours of demand and you can see
the Steep part of the curve of high
demand is
is quite steep so the top five percent
of demand was just for uh five tenths of
a percent of the hours for just 48 Hours
the top ten ten percent of the demand
was for just over one percent of the
hours
um and what's significant is going back
the decading in 2000 we had an average
um asset utilization rate of 67 percent
meaning on average the load was 67
percent of our capacity
um but over the ensuing decade it
dropped to 57 percent meaning we became
a peak year region in fact the most
peaky region in the entire country
um in part because we have just as
intense heat waves as down south or out
west but they don't persist for very
long so we get these big spikes and air
conditioning loads in the summertime
from hot weather but the declining asset
utilization rates meaning we're
spreading the fixed cost of all that
capacity over fewer kilowatt hours so
the cost per kilowatt hour has gone up
and now this is my final slide or next
to final
um which is the so-called duck curve and
and this is an actual hour of of New
England's load
um the black line and as we've added
more solar in the middle of the day
um those lines have been dropping this
is from an ISO New England projection
from a few years back or almost a decade
ago
um of and we're actually sort of in the
middle of that yellow to Orange to Red
dip in the middle of the day typically
from solar that is uh producing in the
middle of the day and then we typically
have a peak in the evening and the
question is can we provide the right
price signals the price right sort of
structural elements so that we have
appropriate incentives to shift load off
a peak particularly as we add new
flexible loads electric vehicles uh
buildings the the inflation reduction
acts as incentives for thermal energy
storage for air conditioning loads for
instance where you could make ice
there's this is a commercial you know
well commercialized product use your air
conditioning system uh on the far left
side of the graph when demand is load to
charge up a block of ice that you can
then use to pull off of to meet your
building air conditioning load at the in
the in the peak and and or can we use
solar which is in Surplus in the middle
of the day use it to charge storage and
use that to discharge that storage uh
and and demand response at that peak
time so that's that's part of our
Challenge and what we would like to see
the vision that we have is that
Community powered generators battery
storage demand response programs can
help
shave those Peaks fill those valleys and
lower the cost per kilowatt hour for all
this installed capacity and to do so
under State jurisdictional Interstate
Market that works in coordinate Nation
with the first jurisdictional interstate
wow
it was like consuming information from a
fire hose Cliff but we're used to that
with you so we thank you for that
excellent presentation I'm going to
start off the questioning here by
asking this question
one of this
primary selling points for the community
power Coalition is that it will lower
costs
you showed us one slide about all the
different Community power organizations
in California
but California has a reputation for
hiring having some of the highest costs
um
well it's a big state
um and
um
in general the the Community Choice
aggregations are offering a lower price
on average than the utilities it's a
little complicated because the utilities
still owns some a generation or had
contracts for it so as they have a
complex overlay of when customers depart
they're able to charge some of that back
to the Community Choice aggregation to
recoup
but what would otherwise be stranded
cost
um
and
I you know I would just observe that
like
us
um
you know I think there to some extent
out on the edge of the pipelines if you
will I I
um I and so
in California they just historically had
high prices but the joint power agencies
the ccas are competing with that and
what they're doing and one of the things
that has attracted us to send analytics
is their robust way of evaluating
proposed deals both the credit risk of
the counterparty the performance risk of
the counterparty but also the economics
of it and at this point the joint power
agencies feel like they're making
decisions that are going to help
stabilize those long-term power costs
um through
um uh
you know the various mechanisms
you know but but I can't I don't I don't
I'm not a student of that market in
detail to understand all the factors
that have gone into their relatively
high prices although I don't know that
they're much higher than we are
um at this point but obviously they've
also had a huge amount of weather
influence climate influenced uh events
uh that have caused a huge cost to
invest in distribution infrastructure
because stuff is burned down and
um
uh you know had had to be rebuilt
so my follow-up question would be what
do you see as the key cost saving
structures within the community power
Coalition I think the biggest element is
having active portfolio management
um uh that is very much risk informed
meaning that in both the utility current
model as well as the broker model is
load is going out to bid for a fixed
term at a particular point in time the
broker model is able to pick and choose
when they go to market although once a
contract is expired they you know have
to go to market again at the end of that
contract expiration
but through that mechanism alone perhaps
they've been able to come up with better
better rates just by being able to have
flexibility when they play the market if
you will
portfolio risk management is an ongoing
process where we're
not probably board members but are
contractors in analytics and eventually
in-house staff will be looking at our
portfolio and what's going on in the
market every single day it'll be
actively managed on a daily basis with
adjusting our positions in various ways
both physical and financial hedging
um and the the long
term value proposition is I think to
look at where we can engage in local
projects and local
demand response such that we're able to
bring on new power from Transportation
electrification perhaps more beat
building uh thermal loads
um being electrified so we're able to
bring on more of that but manage the
peak demand so that we are helping to
spread those costs over over more
kilowatt hours if you will
what what has been shown is that where
these things are enabled there is
actually a lot of demand response
capability and if if demand
and storage can respond to very
short-term price signals they can pull
down those prices at the high end and
actually pull them up a little bit at
the low end although pulling down at the
high end is more dramatic than pulling
up at the low end uh meaning if we shift
load into low demand hours it actually
raises the clearing price but because of
the supply demand curve you know there's
a the everyday generators and storage
bids into the iso New England market and
there's a bit Stark and the lower end of
that is small steps and when you get
towards higher demand the steps go up
really quick so if you can shave those
Peaks and fill them in The Valleys you
see you have much bigger reduction in
the in reducing costs at the high end
than you see in bringing the cost up at
the low end
um so so that is a way in which there's
ultimately a lot more value to be
realized
another attractive
aspect of
the community power Coalition is the
fact that it's a non-profit entity
does your contracts with companies like
Ascend and Calpine which are undoubtedly
for-profit companies dilute
at all the attractiveness of that
non-profit nature
it does a little bit you know we're
paying more for their services than we
would if we could do it in-house
fortunately uh both of them are
accustomed to a model that they've
experienced in California of
um
transferring and we've built it into our
contracts that over time
we can transfer to more of that in-house
and develop and replace their credit
support with our credit support So once
we have Financial reserves and a track
record we'll actually be able to lower
our financing costs our our credit
support uh compared to what we're having
to pay for it from for-profit entities
if you will the other analogy here is
the New Hampshire electric car but
unfortunately I don't have the slide on
that but over the past decade they do
active portfolio management which they
have a small staff that's looking at the
market every day adjusting their
position
um and they have achieved on average
something I can't remember the number so
don't quote me on this something like a
16 average lower default service rate uh
than the investor in utilities through
the fixed price procurement but there's
risk with that too I mean part of the
nature of this is there are risk when
you start managing a portfolio the way
the utilities do it there's no risk to
the utility because they just go out to
bid on schedule but there's risk to the
customers because we end up paying
really high prices for periods of time
so so ultimately I mean there there's
not there's more than a zero percent
chance that that we may someday fail
um but we're structured so we insulate
that from our member communities there's
no recourse back to the taxpayers of the
communities except for the rates we
charge
um but so there's also a good chance
that you know we see the opportunity to
succeed and that's what we're going to
try to do
to be a representative Reynolds has a
question
no representative uh Carmen has a
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again for taking my question this is
actually a three-part question but the
second two depend on the first so I'm in
Lebanon and we're going to be online
soon
now my understanding is that not only is
it opt out but that I will have a choice
of getting power from renewable sources
okay good so
next two parts
is there a price differential for that
compared with other sources and then is
that going to be a model available in
other communities as well beyond Lebanon
um we're we're expecting at this point
to launch with four products
um and they're we're calling the first
two Granite basic and granite plus
Granite basic would just match the
minimum RPS compliance so that'll be the
lowest cost product
uh Granite plus which which right now
that's around 23 24
renewable uh component
um Granite plus would be 33 or about 10
percent more we expect that we'll also
be under the default service price
although how much we don't know and
that's that's going to be achieved by a
combination of renewable energy credits
and what are called ibts internal
bilateral transactions with large hydro
and carbon free so we're building that
as 30 percent 33 renewable or carbon
free Carbon free is large hydro and and
nuclear basically in New England and you
you can actually do what's called an a
contract where you're actually buying
the output of that that is used to
offset your you know it's part of your
settlement with ISO New England
um and so likewise we'll be doing a
clean 50 and a clean 100 which is 50 to
100 renewable or clean energy those we
expect to be more expensive because we
have to buy more wrecks
um uh uh than the default service price
but it would give people the option to
up upgrade to 50 to 100 renewable what
that means is that we either through
direct bilateral contracts or through
acquiring renewable energy credits we
are offsetting that portion of your load
with renewable or clean energy that's
putting into the grid
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair this is
regarding uh slide 44 which um is the
peak demand slide and the date on it is
2016. we've been hearing information
that the peak demand is moving to the
winter in New Hampshire
um and so this is quite outdated are you
finding that the peak load for for this
is moving to the winter months and is
that affecting what you offer and how
you how you approach it
thank you
um
I I think there has been that Trend
um and part of it is the increase of uh
heat pumps
um and that's expected to kind of
continue although air conditioning loads
may also continue to grow in the summer
months
um
and I mean this happens I don't know
this may have been even Massachusetts
data yeah I think this was actually
Massachusetts data but it doesn't look
that different uh for New Hampshire
specific or more recent data you can see
at the very far left and Far Right edge
of the graph there's there's some high
particularly on the left which is
January and February that year you can
see some relatively high prices and you
can see the dip in the spring as well as
in the fall
um
uh but yeah I think that's going to
affect how this is is thought about and
I think they'll be increasing a thought
about you know even even for those
heating demands if there's storage
opportunities for that traditionally
there have been ways to um
uh store
um you know I
for instance I have a buffer tank off of
a pallet boiler but there's now
um uh water uh air-to-water heat pumps
coming online that could actually uh you
could actually build up a store of hot
water at those lower demand times and
then draw in that for both your domestic
hot water and your heating load that's
that's a very commercially feasible
technology if you had access to the
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman in one of your one
of your slides
um I think you you showed that there was
a potential
for
um you to become a even larger supplier
than
um the utilities eversource I think
um
given the fact that you're relying on
the utilities eversource you until
Liberty for distribution
um
it do you foresee at some point that you
know you may have to get into the
distribution business
um simply because it's not going to be
economically viable for those utilities
to continue to provide that service well
I think the actual utilities are quite
ambivalent
about their role in power supply meaning
they don't they don't make a profit on
their power procurement for default
service it's a they get to pass through
their cost so they recover their cost
they account for their cost of issuing
the RFP evaluating the RFP the time at
the puc getting it approved
but they don't make a profit on it what
they make a profit on is investment in
in distribution facilities
um and that's really the business
they're in now now I I would say that I
think some of the utilities have mixed
feelings about this some of them are
indicating they'd like to be in charge
of developing distributed energy
resources
um and
um you know there's a proposal right now
for Unitil develop a 4.99 uh uh megawatt
solar project possibly with storage
um based on the same kind of value stack
that we were looking at it at Senate
Bill 321 and they're saying this can
provide benefits to you know all the
customers because it's actually a lower
cost option than than the market price
of electricity and it lowers
transmission costs and so forth
um
so what's my point
um um I'm sorry uh
that happens to me all the time yeah
your question again
um I was concerned that I was concerned
that
um
um you know
a situation may develop where utilities
are oh yeah are not interested in
providing distribution well yeah so I
they I mean
so they don't I mean a couple of the
utilities of including the cop have been
quite encouraging
um and saying that this is this is a
model that seems to make sense for for
the community I mean the co-op's an odd
one because they keep telling us they
they you know want to help make this
happen but in their case we kind of tell
communities that have the co-op that
you're probably best off just with the
co-op we're probably not going to beat
the co-op price and it is a
democratically managed organization and
they're doing some pretty cool things
with a transactive energy pilot
um but aside from that
um I what what I hope we you know we're
we're in a little bit of uh issues with
the utilities trying to work out our
data needs and how this is all going to
work
um on the one hand and they really you
know want to control their metering
systems and limit the options that we
can do for billing but on the other hand
uh there's um we're I'm also working
with the utilities on the data platform
governance Council so there's also a
sense that this is a opportunity for a
new level of collaboration that could be
very good for both the utilities and the
local communities that they support over
time
well
it was an excellent session and we thank
you Cliff for driving over here to be
with us today
and we're going to take a five or three
minute or five yeah five minute break
before we start our public hearings on
Senate bill on House Bill 418 so for the
next five minutes we're in recess I
encourage everybody to talk to Cliff
offline he will send us this
uh we'll go from there so we're in
I'm going to open the hill hearing on
House Bill 419.
and before I introduce the 418 rather
before I introduce the prime sponsor I
want alert to alert everyone
to the fact that if you want to speak on
this bill
including if you are the sponsor
please submit a pink card these go into
the official record that our clerk
representative Bernardi keeps on every
bill so these pink cards need to be in
the in the folder
these pink cards also help us as we go
through the hearing process decide
how much time will be allocated to each
speaker if we have a lot of pink cards
then we'll have fewer
minutes allocated to each speaker but we
can't make that decision until we get
the pink card so I urge you all if
you're interested in speaking
thank you to
and with that
will now turn the floor over to the
prime sponsor of House Bill 418
thank you chair Bose
for the record my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams I represent South
Concord which includes this District
Welcome to my district it's a pleasure
to host you I'm a member of this
committee and I'm thrilled to be
presenting our first bill at our first
hearing because yesterday's was canceled
due to snow so here we are kicking it
off for the legislative session in 2023.
um so I just want to start by saying
that it's important that we as the
science technology and energy committee
uh cite our sources I know
um chair Bose mentioned this at our
initial orientation and so what I've
done is I've emailed everybody on the
committee
um a PDF of different hyperlinks and
documents many of them are voluminous so
instead of printing out hundreds of
pages to hand to all of you I just sent
around an email that has links so you're
welcome to peruse that after this
hearing that's just the reference
material that I will be speaking to some
of it is very dense
all right so let's talk about how spell
um the affectionate nickname of this
bill is to end wreck sweeping
so let's start with just a quick
overview of the renewable greenhouse gas
initiative in New Hampshire which will
give you some background as to why we
need this bill and what this bill is all
about
first according to the Department of
energy the renewable greenhouse gas
initiative is a multi-state initiative
including many states in the Northeast
New Hampshire Connecticut Delaware Maine
Maryland Massachusetts New Jersey and
New York Rhode Island and Vermont it's a
cap and trade program to address CO2
emissions from the power sector
so New Hampshire adopted Reggie in 2008
we joined many of these states is just
listed and we created a market for
emissions
New Hampshire emissions allowances are
then sold at quarterly auctions and the
proceeds fund our Energy Efficiency fund
the Energy Efficiency fund is a
dedicated fund and it comes from these
Reggie auction proceeds
in an effort to limit
and this is the words of the Department
of energy
the financial impact of Reggie on New
Hampshire ratepayers statute currently
dictates that all amounts in excess of
the threshold price of one dollar for
any allowance sale shall be rebated to
all retail electric rate payers in the
state on a kilowatt per hour basis and
this is the problem that house bill 418
aims to solve
so let's just talk about the amount of
money from Reggie auction proceeds
specifically this is based on data from
eversource but generally you know
there's an average you know we're
talking about the amount of money that
is being refunded every year to rate
payers across the state so this is an
average my math is based on the rate of
0.362 cents per kilowatt hour
and then the assumed amount of
usage per month
so we're looking at an average of 650
kilowatt hours per month for residential
customer
so that means that you receive 2.35
cents per month or 28 dollars and 24
cents per year rebated on average as a
residential Electric customer
so this is once again just based on
eversource it's an average the number
May Vary depending on your usage and
your family size and your household side
Etc et cetera but about 2.35 cents a
month about 28.24 cents per year rebate
so what is Rec Sweeping in New Hampshire
all right so New Hampshire is one of 29
states that have implemented the
renewable portfolio standard
these are state level policies they're
responsible for approximately half of
all growth in the U.S renewable electric
generation and capacity since 2000 so 23
years of growth and that's a good thing
I think we're talking about switching
our source from fossil fuels to
Renewables as the market shifts that way
and it's become sort of the next step in
energy across the nation
so New Hampshire's RPS our renewable
portfolio standard obligates electric
suppliers like eversource unit sale
Liberty we've all had presentations from
them they are required to acquire a
certain percentage of their electricity
mixed from renewable energy sources
every year
so there are four categories number
class one new renewable energy class two
new solar class 3 existing bio mass and
methane less for existing small Hydro
hmm
so there are three ways that electricity
suppliers can comply with renewable
energy obligations under the renewable
portfolio standards and this is where we
get into the Crux of the matter the
first is to buy renewable energy credits
we call them Rex Recs so every megawatt
hour of electricity generated from a
renewable energy system produces a wreck
this is a certificate acknowledging its
potential contribution to the renewable
portfolio standard so electricity
suppliers can purchase wrecks from
homeowners businesses municipalities or
other owners of renewable energy systems
to comply with their RPS obligations
using the rec Market this is the carrot
this is really what we were intending I
believe as a state when we set up this
funding mechanism for renewable energy
credits
the second way that the utilities can
electric suppliers it's not just
utilities obviously constellation is
subject to this as well the second way
that they can meet this criteria is to
pay an alternative compliance payment or
ACP
so instead of purchasing Rex electricity
suppliers can pay into the state
renewable energy fund and the Public
Utilities Commission uses the money that
is generated by these acps alternative
compliance payments to fund rebate
programs for residential commercial
Municipal and low-income renewable
energy projects
the Third Way
is to build Renewables so if uh energy
supplier wanted to put in a new solar
panel solar array they could do that but
unfortunately we have heavy regulation
that prevents that from happening so
this option is scarcely used
so let's get back to the Crux of this
bill wreck sweeping
we can call it the Rex sweeping Loop
loophole
so
excuse me representative McWilliams
could you suspend for a couple of
minutes I'm going to call a brief recess
of three minutes and we will resume
okay recess over
representative McWilliams will continue
thank you chair Vos
um so let me just
set the tone here I apologize I'm taking
you very far afield
and I want to redirect back into the
language of this specific bill I am
speaking to a preview of coming
attractions for House Bill 234 and so
we'll talk more about that when that one
comes up but back to house bill 418
which is a very simple Bill we're going
to repeal
the Energy Efficiency fund and use of
auction proceeds the entire purpose of
this bill
is to remove the rebate
um so what that means is
instead of giving money back to our rate
payers that I talked about instead of
having a rebate of a value about 28
dollars a year per household that money
instead stays in the fund
and So based on the history of this bill
um and the history of the the Energy
Efficiency fund the intention has been
to use that money to
turn it into three to four times
multiplied for Energy Efficiency
projects across the state and so we have
quite a bit of good data showing that
when we take money from the Energy
Efficiency fund we get that money back
times three or times four in reducing
the amount of energy that is then used
in the future for
for our constituents and rate payers so
big picture this bill is really about
returning the program to the way that it
was intended to be used
um and that's really the the Crux of it
all is bringing it back to let's get to
the intent of the bill let's make sure
that we're actually bringing in all of
the money we intended to bring in and
therefore tripling or quadrupling the
benefit for ratepayers and for the
entire state to reduce overall energy
consumption right if you recall one of
our esteemed experts has spoken about
the negawatt meaning that the most
valuable
increment of measurement for energy that
we don't use is is the negawatt not
using energy at all so Energy Efficiency
allows us to reduce and not use energy
that we don't need to use in layman's
terms that means we're no longer heating
buildings and the outside we don't have
heat going out the windows or out the
roof because we've done Energy
Efficiency work to make the building
more efficient
and so that's the purpose of House Bill
418 is to get us back to Simply
funding the fund completely tripling or
quadrupling that fund into reducing
energy use
and with that I'm happy to take
questions
thank you representative McWilliams I'll
start off with a quick question on line
seven of the bill
there is language that refers to
current or Future Energy Efficiency
resource standards programs can you
describe exactly what those programs
okay give me one second I'll pull up the
so the the first two million dollars of
the program I believe are required to be
um
put into Energy Efficiency at
the municipal scale
and I'm I'm just struggling to find the
exact reference but I believe the first
two million is earmarked of the entire
fund
um
oh here we go there's a there's a
so under current law
if we assume the auction revenue is 43
million
that goes into the Energy Efficiency
fund
3.21 million would go to utilities for
Energy Efficiency programs
and 39.4 million would be rebated back
so let's talk about the Energy
Efficiency programs You've Got 2 million
to Municipal and local governments
that's the one I was thinking of and
that could be things like
um
addressing
Energy Efficiency at your local school
your high school needs to be weatherized
just as an example
then there's a 15 minimum after that 2
million that goes to low income Energy
Efficiency programs
and we currently have
um when I say 0.48 million you know it's
less than a million we currently have a
long wait list of folks who qualify for
low-income Energy Efficiency and just
can't seem to get ahead on the wait list
so funding this program would be
a good first step to reducing that
megawatt and then finally 0.73 million
so 730 000 goes to the all fuels program
which is
administered through the Public
Utilities Commission with a request for
proposals process so those are currently
the three buckets for the way that it is
under current law to answer your
question share bows
thank you my follow-up question would
would be a clarification really
um
the language resource standards
typically applies to
uh
a program that is defined in statute
to accomplish certain things
and your use of the word Energy
Efficiency resource standard
standards here is confusing so I was
wondering if you had clarification but I
think I understand now what you were
attempting to achieve so thank you thank
you cheervos
further questions for representative
McWilliams representative munz ask a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for introducing this bill
um just as a follow-up to the Chairman's
question if I'm if I understand
correctly and maybe you can confirm this
the money that you this that H that this
bill would allocate towards those Energy
Efficiency programs
um it's it the the programs are no
different than what the money is already
the the smaller amount of money is
already being spent on correct
uh thank you very much for the question
uh representative munz yes the intention
here is to increase the overall fund not
to redirect or create additional
programs to put money into it simply as
I mentioned there is this 480 000 for
low income 15 of the overall dollars
that are in the amount that can be used
that number really does need to go up in
order for us to make strides to reduce
energy use and so we're just broadening
the pot
thank you thank you
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh
so representative McWilliams you say
that uh by doing this program we're
gonna we're going to uh give money back
three to fourfold to rate payers yet uh
the average customer is going to have
around thirty dollars a year
more in their electric bill they're not
going to receive thirty dollars but
they're not going to receive not uh 90
to 120 dollars benefit by doing this
program or my misconstruing your your
thank you for the question
representative Bernardi so I think there
are two different pieces to this let me
parse it out the first piece is the
individual rebate that we currently have
you're rounding you know 28 to 30
dollars per rate payer to reduce their
use that number would go down but big
picture when I'm talking about the three
to four times return that's not for an
individual that's for the entire market
and so when we're talking about doing
some of these large projects like the
local high school has a weatherization
effort to reduce the amount of energy
that they're using that reduces the
amount of energy that is being used in
the great pool that is all of New
Hampshire's energy users and therefore
when we talk about the three to four
times return on that initial value of
dollars invested what we're really
talking about is reducing the amount of
energy used in the state and therefore
when we look at it from a very simple
economics perspective we're looking at
supply and demand because the demand has
gone down the supply technically has
gone up and the goal goal here is to
have sort of an overall leveraging of
supply and demand because we've done
these smart projects to reduce Energy
Efficiency at a large scale at things
like high schools we therefore see more
available supply for those individual
rate payers who were receiving a 28
rebate and are now expected to see at
least some greater availability of the
supply and demand in energy in New
Hampshire
what
follow-up so then if I understand what
you're saying is the average customer is
still going to see around a thirty
dollar increase in their electric bill
if we were to adopt this uh and and
maybe a minuscule drop in that because
the high school was uh upgraded in its
energy efficiency
so you're talking about thirty dollars a
year I'm talking about a custom what
right now we've had a massive increase
in electric rates and you're proposing
to add another thirty dollars on top of
that uh so I I want to understand is
that what you're saying
representative Bernardi that it's not
what I am saying
I want to be very clear this program
takes the thirty dollars and it refunds
it back okay so that thirty dollars has
already been taken and a piece of that
has been charged for administrative
costs in order to take it and return it
okay the thirty dollars does not belong
to the rate payer but we've decided as a
legislature to refund it over time this
bill corrects that and instead of doing
a refund the money stays in the fund
where it was intended to have long-term
10 to 15 to 20 year Market impacts to
adjust for are over Reliance on
individual fossil fuel natural gas in
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
representative McWilliams when you're
advocating this bill would instead of
rebating
the money that's already been collected
from ratepayers instead of rebating it
to them in their bills it would
retain it for the Energy Efficiency
programs that all rate payers
you're so you're talking about
that money being invested in Energy
Efficiency
by homeowners businesses communities
that
that have the opportunity you have
achieved efficiency yes they do could
you be referring to
the
when ISO New England was here last week
they showed us one particular picture
in which they showed that Energy
Efficiency
and behind the meter solar had reduced
was reducing the growth of the demand
curve in New England
by four percent below what it would have
been without those resources is that
what you're referring to having New
Hampshire
invest in Energy Efficiency through the
New Hampshire saves program so that we
reduce
demand in the marketplace and thereby
Energy prices for all consumers
representative Reynolds for the question
as I mentioned we're really talking
about a 10 15-year strategy and so the
data that you're referring to from ISO
New England in regards to overall four
percent reduction because of Energy
Efficiency projects is exactly the point
that I'm trying to make we're at four
percent now and we know that that number
will go up if we put more money in this
fund thank you for the question
representative Summers asked your
question
thank you Mr chairman
um look at these numbers and also
falling off of uh representative
Bernardi's question I understand and I
see on here the uh the current rebate 30
and it's it's very close 39.83 to 39.44
million for rebates and then it shows
that on January 1st middle of the winter
next year the rebate goes down to zero
and um just to clarify on the
understanding of the uh
of the amount that the gets passed
through to the constituents and also how
much they rebate how much would their
bill go up
so I think you you asked the question
and answered the question representative
Summers
um
we were talking about about say two
dollars and fifty cents a month on the
average consumer's bill is rebated back
and so that is that 28 dollars per year
that has been historically rebated back
follow up so with with the average
constituents build and go up 28 dollars
in January 1st 2024 when that's not
rebated
so representative Summers I just want to
be super clear this money is already
taken out of their automatic debit or
their checks that they're writing each
month to their energy supplier the money
has been taken and it is refunded back
okay so we're not talking about an
increase because they've already written
the check
and then they get it refunded back so
they've written the check and therefore
they've committed to pay they're just
getting a refund because that's the way
it's structured right now
okay representative lewicki has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um I keep hearing invest and I'm getting
I'd like to know who will all of the
investors so-called benefit from this or
will some investors benefit greatly and
other benefit investors receive nothing
so I understand your question
representative lewicki you're trying to
look for winners and losers in a program
that we have agreed already to
administer for Energy Efficiency because
of long-term planning to reduce the
demand on our electric and energy needs
in the New Hampshire Market
so when you're looking for winners and
losers there's always going to be
somebody who feels like they've had to
contribute and they're not seeing an
immediate result but we're talking about
10 to 15 year planning so the overall
Market is the winner
and therefore there will always be
someone who complains that they had to
pay something in order to benefit the
greater good
follow-up okay thank you Mr chairman
um so now that we're talking about
contributors rather than investors it
appears that would this bill then pick
winners and losers and some of the
losers unlike a real investment where
one has a hope of a return
in this case we are asked to invest and
some of us who have already made
ourselves efficient and have already
done everything we could are going to be
subsidizing those who are chosen by some
organization to be the beneficiaries of
our contributions is that correct
representative lewicki
I understand what you're getting at
and as someone who supports public
education even if I didn't have children
who would benefit from public education
it's the same situation where we're
talking about a market
that is a monopoly that we the
legislature control
and therefore we do have to decide how
to fund the next steps for the market
just like we the legislature decide how
we fund public education and so when you
try to make it pitting one side versus
the other winners versus losers we're
really just talking about long-term
planning for what happens and how it's
going to play out and so I would posit
that the long-term plan for our energy
market right now is
capitalism let the market decide there's
really no guard rails this Returns the
funding back to our goal in 2009 when
this all started was to work on the
transition to Renewables and to focus on
Energy Efficiency this refunds as in
continues to fund the program as it was
initially meant to be funded so we can
get back on that plan
you're welcome
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh for
clarification can you uh under the
current plan
how do our
citizens get rebated right now with that
that's an excellent question and I
believe it's on the electric bill that
the consumer receives they see that
rebate come back
follow-up follow-up
so I guess my point is I I see what
is it not do we not
believe that right now in today's
situation our residents need immediate
relief not relief 10 years from now so
anything that we can do
to keep their electric bills lower right
now would be a plus in them seeing that
we are trying to do something for them
so why would you want to
take that away now when our our
residents need immediate relief
so um you may recall last session at the
end of the session we had an emergency
bipartisan Bill to provide refunds for
our rate payers because I think everyone
in sitting in this room agrees that we
are in an emergency situation when it
comes to cost of energy in New Hampshire
and it was the right thing to do to
provide at least some tangible dollars
back to ratepayers so that they would
feel less of the hurt when the spikes
happened which they did so I would agree
with you that we are currently in a dire
situation but then I think this is where
you and I differ philosophically because
I would say this dire situation that we
are in needs to be addressed with a 10
to 15 year solution and that's what this
bill does it funds a 10 to 15 year
solution to get us back on track to
where we were in 2009 with the guard
rails to make sure that we are
protecting the energy strategy for the
state so when you talk about wouldn't it
be best to give pennies back to
individual rate payers I think that
that's short-term thinking I think that
that may feel like a Band-Aid right now
but the wound is requiring a surgeon not
a Band-Aid
are you representative Nutter has a
question
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um and thank you representative
McWilliams for this um for for this bill
and for taking my question
um pretty straightforward question if we
had a more robust Energy Efficiency
program might we all have avoided the
Christmas Eve debacle
oh um that's an excellent question
representative Wendy Thomas
um I believe that there are two pieces
that go into avoiding spikes the first
is a diversity of sources of energy and
we've kind of created our own pathway
for that by committing to Natural Gas to
the level that we have as a state I
think that there was going to be a spike
due to Ukraine and international issues
that I don't know that we could have
avoided aside from making different
decisions in 2009 or you know even five
years ago so we we are where we are in
terms of our diversity and our our lack
of portfolio mix but the other piece Yes
Energy Efficiency works with the
portfolio mix so it's something we can
do and we should do to mitigate some of
the effects of the spike but it's it's
not a silver bullet unfortunately
you're welcome
notwithstanding the office of the
consumer Advocates character race
characterization of the Christmas Eve
event as a debacle it was simply a
capacity efficient deficiency was not a
debacle
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um just referring
back to representative Doug Thomas's
question and his desire for
consumers rate payers to see immediate
relief from the high prices the high
bills that they're facing is it not true
that the New Hampshire saves program
which
These funds support
are immediately available to all rate
payers and could not anyone any
homeowner any business who is hurting
from high bills could they not
Avail themselves of the New Hampshire
stage programs say upgrade some lighting
or some controls or install some
insulation in their home or business and
see immediate relief
from high energy bills next month and
for the rest of the year and in
perpetuity
representative Reynolds that is the
concept
of the level of funding that we would
like to have in order to make sure that
that really is how it works out in
practice
follow-up quick follow Mr chairman
follow-up so that's not how it works in
practice because the Energy Efficiency
fund the New Hampshire Safe program is
underfunded it isn't what your bill
seeks to achieve is to refund that
program so that everyone who calls can
Avail can get the resources to help the
immediate help they need yes absolutely
thank you for the question that is the
thank you obvious answer yes that's
where we're headed what's what we need
to clarify none of the funds from this
program
go into the New Hampshire saves program
that program is funded by the system
benefits charge
it's confusing but that's the way it
works
well thank you representative McWilliams
for oops one more question
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
yeah my question we just saw a
presentation that talked about the duck
curve and how in the state
um part of what contributes to our
problems with rates is uh is the Peaks
and you talked about supply and demand
so I guess the question is
um
there's a concern for a lack of plan at
this point you talk about long-range
planning right a lack of plan for
shaving that peak in a way that actually
lowers rates for everybody because we
need less energy coming into the state
right we have to pay for Less so
um I guess is there any way you could
speak to what this is about 10 times the
money
uh that's currently going into the
program from Reggie that would be added
um
can you talk about how you would expect
that to work over time or what kind of
economies of scale you think we would
get in terms of being able to
um better manage our demand
thank you for the question
representative McGee I think that they
that may actually be a better question
for the Department of Environmental
Services and I know they're here but I
do think that in Broad Strokes as a
legislator the goal here of course is to
make a large impact so we can address
that low-hanging fruit which is Energy
Efficiency we know that there are
projects that can be funded if the funds
are available it's just been starved for
money for so long that we can't even get
at the low-hanging fruit in the state
and we all suffer because of it so I
think that if you could ask that
question when Des is up I think that's
probably the best way to respond okay
thank you
okay thank you
so
uh we thank you representative uh
McWilliams for introducing your bill
I'll next call on Mr Griffin robarge
thank you Mr chairman uh
for the record uh Griffin Roberts from
the New Hampshire Department of energy
uh testifying in opposition to House
Bill 418 FN as introduced
um in referencing the fiscal note
um just wanted to clear up some uh
confusion that might be had in the
fiscal note
um if you look at the funding source
that's the gray shaded box here you'll
see that there's a indication that it
impacts General funds and Highway funds
we believe that to be an error that's
been made this is only impacting Energy
Efficiency related Energy Efficiency
fund related dollars
um
regarding the Department's opposition
again just referencing the fiscal note
and using last year's Reggie proceeds as
a reference
there was some
39.32 million that was approximately
rebated back to ratepayers if this bill
were to go forward it would instead
rebate all or allocate all Reggie
proceeds into Energy Efficiency programs
with no rebates going back to Electric
customers in a time of historically High
electric costs the department feels that
passing on another
approximately 40 million dollars onto
rate payers
um might be ill-advised just at this
time given the give again given where
rates are obviously uh the the fiscal
note uh was put together by both
Departments of energy and the Department
of Environmental Services
um there would be a a near-term increase
in electric costs if these rebates were
done away with for electric customers
but the both departments do acknowledge
that over the long term increased
investments in Energy Efficiency would
save ratepayers money over the long term
but again focusing on the short-term
implications of this bill that's where
our opposition lies
regarding current Energy Efficiency
programs as this body is aware House
Bill 549 was signed into law last year
that made some increases to the budgets
and New Hampshire saves programs and
Energy Efficiency programs so New
Hampshire is not devoid of Energy
Efficiency programs currently
um
people can obviously whether you're a
commercial or industrial customer or
resident can certainly work with your uh
utility and see what types of programs
New Hampshire state offers see what you
might qualify for and then determine the
best path forward but again an
additional 40 million dollars based on
last year's data on to rate payers at
this time is something the department
strongly has concerns with and with that
that concludes my testimony and I'll
take any questions
thank you Mr robarge one quick question
is it your understanding that the
language of this bill would redirect
some of these auction proceeds refunds
to the New Hampshire saves program so
and how would that work yes and thank
you for the question so I I don't mean
to steal uh I don't mean to avoid your
question but the Department of
Environmental Services did come with a
little printout demonstrating how funds
are allocated and I just respectfully
defer to them because it's their handout
so I think they can better answer that
question but
um it's my understanding that there is a
small portion of funds right now that
currently go into New Hampshire saves
programs from these funds
okay thank you representative Thomas has
a question Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
could you clarify please because it's
been mentioned several times about
everybody uh benefits from uh in this
are there qualifications for people to
get funds from that fund do they have to
meet certain qualifications there can be
depending on the program so I'm not I'm
not you know going to go through every
single program here for New Hampshire
saves but there are ones that do Target
low-income households that might give
them more of a benefit than you would
say
no disrespect to anybody living in Rye
but somebody who lives in Rye
um so
um you know there are certain programs
like that that might give them a little
bit of an edge there's also additionally
um other Assistance programs that the
department presented uh when we were
here you know the electric assistance
program the weatherization assistance
program which is currently uh wait
listed but there are programs out there
for people to Avail themselves up but
just you know look to talk to utilities
to learn about what those programs offer
what you might qualify for
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming
back
um can you confirm that the annual
impact on rates is
um 28 a year so thank you for the
question so
and uh representative McWilliams just
following up on the information you and
I had exchanged um so the information
that representative McWilliams had
referenced is information in an Ever
source file and currently before the puc
on their standard cost recovery charge
that data is based on historical uh
Reggie rebate information
if there was something more recent uh to
use as a case example I refer you to the
annual Reggie report that's put out
um which I know Des will likely
reference when they're up here but there
is a section in there about
Trends and electric rates and
net rate impact was
.00032 cents per kilowatt hour which
translates into about 21 cents per month
for a tip excuse me for a typical
residential customer
um so again
based on the information representative
McWilliams provide it can be vastly
different depending on how future
auctions go but I don't want to speak
too much for eversource but that's at
least my impression of their filing
follow-up follow-up so this that's a big
if I understand correctly there's a big
difference between 21 cents a month and
2.50 cents a month I would yes correct
can you reconcile those two so I can
only I can only kind of I can't predict
what future Reggie auctions will look
like I can only reference at least what
was in the past Reggie report as to what
was done in the most recent auction and
what the impacts of that were obviously
with the eversource data that was
referenced that's still ongoing
um and I don't want to speak too much on
that just because I can't predict what
Reggie uh proceeds will look like in the
future
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um this is um in reference to the last
uh last full paragraph on the fiscal
note where it says over the long term
increased investment in Energy
Efficiency projects would save rate
payers money
so my question is how does the
department of energy propose to get us
rate payers those long-term Energy
savings if we don't start now sure so as
I'm thank you for the question as I
mentioned New Hampshire is not devoid of
Energy Efficiency programs now House
Bill 549 was passed and signed into law
last year that made changes to Energy
Efficiency budgets and everything like
that made increases to them so we're not
devoid of that in terms of in it is it
is true that over the long term there
will be if there is increased investment
you know it will save ratepayers money
but again at a time where electric rates
are at some of the highest they've ever
been an additional 40 million dollars on
ratepayers at this time would be
something that the department just wants
to express significant concern about
because it would you know impact uh
certainly low to moderate income
representative muns thought of another
question
thank you Mr chairman
um
I don't think anybody disagrees that
rate payers are are really being
impacted right now by the by the rate
increases
um and it is an extraordinary
circumstance
I guess my question is in the budgeting
process that state agencies are now
going through with the governor has the
department of energy made a case to the
governor to use part of the State
Surplus to reduce short-term uh energy
rates so that we can allow we can use
this money to continue to invest in the
future sure and thank you for the
question you know I would just point
back to the to House Bill 2023 which has
passed in which was uh passed by the
legislature during the veto session last
year
um so that is a current program right
now to offer you know immediate bill
assistance to those at the lower ends of
the socioeconomic ladders and you know
people certainly can reach out to their
cap agencies to learn what they might
qualify for and everything like that I
not intimately involved in the
Department's discussions with uh the
budget but it's certainly something I
could ask and follow up with the
committee on but I can at least just
point to House Bill 2023 as some
legislative action that occurred in the
near past
okay my thanks to the department for
your input on this legislation
we have one other pink card it was
submitted by the Department of
Environmental Services Michael
Fitzgerald in particular
he said he would make himself available
if the committee had questions
particularly about this handout that
they that the department provided
does the committee wish to ask questions
of Mr Fitzgerald
yes so Mr Fitzgerald if you could come
and who has that first question
representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman
welcome Mr Fontaine and yes
oh we've got to turn the mic on
the record uh Mike Fitzgerald I'm the
assistant director of the air division
in the Department of Environmental
Services I'm joined by Joe Fontaine
who's the Reggie program manager we are
the agency that implements the Reggie
program jointly with doe we're
responsible for the participation and
the uh
um uh in the auction programs and and
the revenue once the revenue comes in
that money goes to doe and they're
responsible for statute to deal with the
revenue in accordance with the chart
that I provided so sorry thank you Mr
Fitzgerald appreciate it thank you for
being here
um I recently saw a report on the
regional Reggie program and how the
different states are Distributing their
funds and the thing that I made note of
is the pie charts that showed how much
money was going to rebates or other
costs and how much was going into Energy
Efficiency and the piece of the pie that
New Hampshire is providing for Energy
Efficiency was kind of Converse to what
the other states are supporting
um in in most of the other states it was
between like 79 and 85 I think so so my
first question I I have two is um
is uh has that been consistent the whole
time can you give us some context around
how much money we're we're investing and
or
losing by the way we're administering
the program as opposed to the other
competitive states in the region sure by
way of context
um Reggie program began in 1999
and
our participation
um and it was it was a joint initiative
of 11 states and
um the way the program was designed was
that CO2 auction revenues would be
distributed to States and each state
would be able to make their own decision
and and in accordance with their own
priorities
New Hampshire legislature and adopting
Reggie
originally allocated a significant
portion of the funds to Energy
Efficiency programs ultimately that was
changed I believe in 2012 when there was
a compromise achieved in the legislature
and I will say that Des position by the
way is is that um
uh you know we believe participation in
Reggie in general is a positive benefit
for New Hampshire because the wholesale
cost of
uh the Reggie program allowance is is
embedded in the cost of a wholesale
electricity and our therefore if we
participate and we receive our revenues
back we're better off financially the
debate is what to do with those revenues
as was pointed out by the representative
and so
um uh the compromise that was achieved
in 2012 was uh that the one dollar of
each allowance price would be dedicated
to Energy Efficiency at that time
allowance prices were roughly uh two two
dollars
plus or minus and
um since that time the price of
allowances has risen as it
was always projected to the number of
allowances decreased lowering CO2
emissions over time but the price of
each allowance has increased today Joe
Revenue allowance prices roughly 12
range from 13 to 14 13 to 14 so when
that compromise was achieved in 1999 the
one dollar represented approximately 50
percent of the revenues
um today it represents less than 10
percent because the price of the
allowances has increased again our
position is that it's up to the
legislature to determine what how those
funds are allocated but that's been the
traditional
um so that that amount that's gone into
Energy Efficiency
um traditionally as a percentage has
declined as the price of allowances has
increased thank you that's a very
important piece of context and so the
follow-up question was around the
allowance prices
um oh Mr chair I had said I had a
two-part but
all right follow up thank you
um
so I had read recently that the
allowance prices are projected to
continue to go up and I don't you know I
don't follow the market so I don't know
if that's true or not but um but you
have made
a fairly clear point that the percentage
of what we're receiving as a state uh
has has not stayed commiserate in terms
of what we're investing out of that
money so if it was a let's say 14 just
for easy math right we would be putting
seven dollars of the 14 into
um and we're still at the one dollar
rate so we're basically not keeping up
what I don't know if I would use the
term keeping up but we're basic
basically we're many of the other states
uh have chosen to invest a greater
significant percentages into
um into into Energy Efficiency can I
just ask one more question uh it's still
along the same line well we're
restricting to two questions per member
until all members have asked a question
and we are running short of time here so
representative lewicki is recognized for
a question
um thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I am interested in knowing how things
we basically have several different
states and several different
methodologies and do you and it might
have been a better question for Mr
Roberts have any idea of whether the
rate increase in in the other states
have been similar to greater than lesser
than those in New Hampshire recently
certainly can't speak for all the Reggie
States there's there's 11 states in the
program but those states that are in the
iso New England region I believe that
the cost increases
have been somewhat commensured it's been
somewhat higher or lower but there's
been significant cost increase rate
increases in all the iso New England
states I believe it's consistent
bottom line the the cost of energy is
primarily related to the cost of fuel
and and in New England and probably a
significant portion of the country that
cost of fuel is natural gas and the cost
of natural gas has risen dramatically so
that's
um that's been the primary driver and I
believe that's fairly consistent across
the Reggie region
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um we actually saw a couple of weeks ago
in a presentation I forgot whether it
was the iso or the group that spoke
after
um but that showed that transmission
costs are um an increasingly large part
of what rate payers are paying
um can you speak a little bit to the
effects of Energy Efficiency on
transmission costs and particularly how
they contribute to reducing Peak costs
Peak shaving that sort of thing sure
um
that's a key point for for the Energy
Efficiency discussion
um uh yes transmission costs uh have
increased and ISO New England does
project
um additional transmission costs
necessary to ensure reliability over the
next next several years ISO New England
also does an Energy Efficiency report
each year indicating the amount of
energy efficiency and its impact on the
uh
overall demand and and Peak demand and I
can send a link to the
committee of that report but it does
indicate that
the iso New England projects significant
reductions in
the need for additional transmission as
a result of investments in Energy
Efficiency and those Investments do
have a significant uh impact on all
ratepayers not just those who take
advantage of the efficiency programs
those who take advantage of the
efficiency programs get a direct benefit
but all of those investments in Energy
Efficiency and reducing the peak do have
a a beneficial impact on reducing
transmission the need for additional
transmission
follow-up
thank you um somewhat unrelated but
could you also talk a little bit about
what is actually
um in these individual programs that are
funded by Reggie how individual projects
well I didn't uh Fontaine and I did
provide this this slide and I do want to
correct one one Minor error on it but it
shows on one side the current
Investments
from Reggie and uh if uh just beginning
up at the upper left
um we should use the figure 43 million
dollars that's the New Hampshire portion
of of Reggie Investments that's data
from last August
um that was the amount of Revenue that
New Hampshire received
um that money goes into the Energy
Efficiency fund moving to the right
there's approximately a third of a
million dollars in administrative costs
between us doe salaries and so on for Mr
Fontaine and others a doe who do all the
accounting for this then uh based on the
dollar threshold that I spoke about the
one dollar of each allowance that
reflects on the left hand side moving
down the column uh 3.21 million dollars
goes into the Energy Efficiency programs
in the utilities and that's broken up
into the three boxes below
um the alternative the all fuels program
the low income program and the municipal
and governments program
and then uh third of that 43 million
39.4 million goes into uh the rebates
that go back to residential and
Commercial customers
um those do in a responsive question
that was previously asked those do go
back in the form
of a decrease in the rate it's built
into the rate you don't see an you don't
see a rebate you don't get a check you
uh those rebates
um are are put back into the to the
kitty so to speak and those rebates go
uh to reduce the rate uh of of them and
then under this bill I just want to
indicate we did make one minor mistake
here that
um the uh uh what's in this this bill
would repeal what is in uh this this box
Joe
this whole right side the whole right
side okay so all of that money would
then
um uh nah
this reveals the rebates right yeah
right yeah yeah
so the whole whole 39.44 million would
go over to the left box
um and
um so again there's there's a minor
mistake on this on the second page we'll
correct that and send a revised chart to
so
could you help me uh
understand if I made an error here when
I said that uh that Reggie money doesn't
go to New Hampshire saves was that
incorrect is Reggie money in fact go to
New Hampshire says the Reggie money
under current statute does go into the
programs run by the utilities
um but the language that you pointed out
is is an error because the Energy
Efficiency resource standard I mean it's
just a that language is not defined I
don't think but the Energy Efficiency
resource standard as you correctly
pointed out does not exist the uh the
current statute does say
the one dollar
under the threshold goes in as a
supplement it goes into the money that
is that is currently allocated from the
SBC
so New Hampshire saves is funded by both
Reggie money and SBC monies correct
thank you for that clarification yes
uh representative Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I just want a clarification
on your last statement there regarding
um
money's going into the um uh rate I
guess for for utilities so if this bill
were passed
are you saying that the um that that
would cause a increase in the rates
because that money would no longer be
subtracted from that and there are
residents would see that as another rate
increase by our utilities as Mr robes
pointed out that there would be a
short-term I think
uh there's some confusion over
short-term versus long term because
um we've been speaking about short-term
costs since 1999 2000 and there's been
significant Investments that have gone
into Energy Efficiency and are now
actually reducing rates so but
yes if this this bill would take money
that is currently being rebated to
customers
and would reallocate it into Energy
Efficiency programs that provide a
benefit over over time increasing the
benefit that's already been received
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman just following up
on
representative Thomas's question looking
for more clarification
electric rates
on every customer's bills are
there's about seven different items
correct so eversource Unitil Liberty
there
rates are transmission and distribution
charges
and there's of course the systems
benefits charge
small sense or cents and fractions of
sense so
under current practice where the 43
million in total is being rebated to
all customers
is it fair to say that the reduction in
rate is probably in the third decimal
place
on customers bills sure
in accordance with the report that we
provided to the legislature last October
and Based on data from last summer the
uh the rate the input to the rate as a
result of the Reggie
revenues and that cost as I mentioned is
embedded in the wholesale cost of
electricity when it's purchased from the
supplier
so that cost was approximately 21 cents
on an average bill this bill would
reallocate that 21 cents per month to
um
investments in the Energy Efficiency
program
so
do you need a follow-up could I yes so
to clarify the
difference on someone's on the average
bill which I believe you always use 600
kilowatt hours consumption of 600
kilowatt hours per year
the change in their bill that they would
not given would be 21 cents per month
on their bill in in Aggregate and that
would ultimately again that money's yeah
21 cents per month on their bill it
would be 21 cents on the bill yes
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm going to want to follow up on a
on a comment that you made uh just a few
minutes ago when you talked about you I
think you mentioned that
um there has been that the Investments
that were made
uh from the money in Reggie have started
to have a noticeable impact on rates
can you give us any sense of what that
is I mean in terms of
um you know cents per month on someone's
bill
uh I don't have that information with me
at the moment but I can certainly
um
take a look at it I will refer you also
to the Reggie program
annual report which outlines the costs
and benefits
received from Reggie Investments for the
region as a whole and the uh and and New
Hampshire and we can we can supply you
with a link to that like I can't speak
to the specific number at the moment
follow-up uh okay let's move on
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh I I just want
to confirm your your statement that you
take no or the Des takes no position on
whether or not this uh bill should move
forward uh it is the legislature's
responsibility to decide where these
monies go uh that is correct yes thank
uh who's next here representative Wendy
Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for being here um you
testified earlier that Des manages the
Reggie program and oversees the auctions
yes
um so is it fair to say that um Des is
very involved in the oversight and
management of many aspects of energy
responsibility lies with the Department
of Energy Des
prior to the Department's Inception a
few a few years ago
did provide a significant amount of
testimony on on legislative issues
related to energy as there's as related
to its impact on the environment and
um uh and and so uh but again in general
we defer to the Department of energy at
this point in time for their input on
um energy costs yes thank you um so can
you just outline the responsibilities
Des has for energy in New Hampshire sure
um
Reggie is again a an
alliance of 11 states the Reggie
Inc board of directors is composed of
one energy agency and one environmental
agency from each state in New Hampshire
that is commissioner Bob Scott of the
Department of Environmental Services for
environment and uh commissioner Jared
from the Department of from the
Department of energy that board guides
the overall Reggie program
um New Hampshire Des has responsibility
under statute for our participation in
the auctions and
um the statute is very specific about
our requirements and and so on and then
when that Revenue comes in that money
goes into the efficiency Energy
Efficiency fund and the Energy
Efficiency fund is
um the purview of the Department of
energy and again the statute directs how
that how those funds should be used and
this bill would affect that
thank you thank you uh Mr Fitzgerald now
to remind members that when you're
asking questions you want to be asking
questions about the bill in front of us
not general questions
representative reshni has a question
uh thank you for taking my question
thank you chairman
so this this will increase the money
from 3 million to 43 million starting
January 1st 2024.
um how would that's a large increase
would the department be able to spend
that much money and what happens to the
um I think that question is better
suited for the Department of energy but
I would say that I certainly believe
they would be prepared to in in my
opinion they would be prepared to to
invest that money is directed by
investment into programs that already
exist so it would just be uh an influx
of of cash and um the programs are
generally administered by the utilities
they would need to gear up for
additional investment but I don't I
don't think the department would have a
significant impact but I defer to Mr
so I would follow up on that by asking
the question if a three-year try in a
triennium Energy Efficiency plan was in
effect
which already had budgets for the three
years of the program yes what a big
infusion of cash like this uh
necessitate a
a redo a rebuild a revision of the
um without benefit of particular
expertise I would say in general I would
think so but I again I would defer to I
think the registry money is an addition
to that yeah I mean the reg the Reggie
money is is goes into the same pot of
money that the SBC goes to so
um it would be a significant increase
there would be a significant additional
amount of money available in that pot to
be distributed to the utilities and you
know that would go then into Energy
Efficiency programs contractors that do
Audits and Energy Efficiency uh uh
installations and so on but I I don't
think
the amount of money would have a
significant impact on
how the state responds that the
utilities would need to gear up and the
contractors right thank you
okay I don't see any further hands up so
I thank you to gentlemen for being here
thank you and I would like to close the
public hearing on House Bill 418.
we will now take a recess for lunch and
we will return at one o'clock at which
time we will open a public hearing on
House Bill 576
establishing an energy conservation
program and an energy conservation
project fun and establishing the state
Pace Reserve fund thank you we'll see
foreign
this is your one minute warning we will
okay good afternoon everyone and welcome
back to the Tuesday January 24th session
of the science technology and energy
committee we will be hearing
and holding two public hearings this
afternoon
the First on House Bill
576 establishing an energy conservation
program
and an energy conservation project fund
and establishing the state Pace Reserve
fund
after that public hearing we'll hold
another public hearing on House Bill 92
requiring the adoption of innovative
vehicle emission standards pursuant to
section 177 of the federal Clean Air Act
we were originally scheduled to hear or
to have an executive session on four
bills at four o'clock this afternoon
those bills were HB 633 HB 211 HB 234
and HB 246.
the executive session on those four
bills will be canceled and rescheduled
so watch your calendar on Thursday of
this week
for information about the rescheduled
executive sessions on those four bills
why are we doing that because we haven't
heard those four bills yet we were going
to hear them yesterday but that didn't
happen so
we will be hearing them in the future
and then scheduling exec sessions after
hearing those bills
so with that I would like to now open
the public hearing on House Bill 576
establishing an energy conservation
program and an energy conservation
project fund and establishing the state
Pace Reserve fund
and before I introduce the bill sponsor
I want to refresh everyone's memory that
the committee cannot accept
an amendment to a bill until
executive session
therefore if you're introducing a bill
and you already have an amendment to the
bill you can talk about it in general
terms but you can't refer to the
amendment specifically
so with that I'd like to turn the floor
over to representative mangaputi welcome
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members for presenting the bill HB
576 I will try to give an
um my PhD thesis presentation of PACE
program
because that's how much work I had to
put in to kind of make it
understandable in our
state what we have right now configured
so
um
HB 576
if you re recall
a similar bill I had brought in uh
two two terms ago but let me explain a
little bit of what PACE program is why
the this bill is
necessary especially given our situation
in the state where we need housing we
need energy cost to go down and
infrastructure and federal funding
that's available
for all these purposes we need an
enabling legislation at the state level
so the local communities can adopt this
thank you so Pace programs are typically
enabled through State legislation and
authorized at the local government level
commercial pace which this bill
addresses property assessed clean energy
is a financing mechanism to allow
commercial property owners to finance
energy Improvement for existing building
over a long term
it also helps
uh
this the rate the pace
um investment of financing if it is done
through Pace the rates are different
lower and because they are attached to
the property itself which means there is
a less risk of default so it is
uh
property assessed clean energy
in typical PACE program allows of
commercial industrial and multi-family
buildings over five units not under five
units over five units to make energy
improvement over a long term up to 20
years
the loan is repaid via a municipal
betterment assessment on the property
and attached to the property so the
benefits and payments flow to the
subsequent purchaser so it stays with
the purchaser under Pace financing
eligible energy improvements include
energy consumption reduction
which is conservation and efficiency
renewable energy gas line extensions
sewer and water line uh changes so
basically
infrastructure modification
more than 37 States in Washington DC
have adopted sea Pace enabling
legislation because of the opportunities
for investment in local businesses
energy and cost saving and job creation
we all know that energy cost has gone up
tremendously and homeowners to business
owners to
big companies are wrestling with that
and trying to make sense of how they can
um contain or
invest in improvements okay and simply a
put c-pace uses borrowed Capital to pay
for The Upfront costs associated with
Energy Efficiency and renewable energy
improvements unlike other project
financing The Borrowed capital is repaid
over a time over time via voluntary tax
assessment
so and then you have a handout
um I do have the you know an amendment
that I try to bring in but you have the
copy of it and uh the other one I want
to uh
look at I want you to look at is
residential property assessed clean
energy
this is in existence
in 33 States
and if you see
New Hampshire is in early stages
on the map
this is because in 2015 there were
somewhat of a PACE program that existed
that was privately instituted and
implemented through johnsonwood
foundation and there was a person
that was uh
employed and and her name first name was
Lauren I don't remember the last name
now and there are two communities that
adopted that somewhat of a PACE program
uh because state had enabled that was
Nashua and Dover to communities that
adopted that and the person was
responsible for the fund and execution
and all that when she left the state
it went with her
so last time I tried to recreate that
and bring that back and there was a lot
of hurdles and I this time I've tried to
make it more an enabling so again I want
to emphasize that unless
State puts an enabling legislation
to use the state enabled program funding
that's Federal Department of energy is
funneling money for you know channeling
money uh to the states
unless we have a state enable
legislation we no community in New
Hampshire can access it
so this is what um I am trying to show
and there's also the residential
property is not my bill that is our pace
C basis commercial
uh property assessed clean energy
program cbase is what my bill addresses
and that's why it's five
um
uh units or more and Senator Waters is a
co-sponsor and I talked to him
personally he would have loved to come
here and testify but he has no heat or
electricity at his home so he said I
cannot make it to the state and I can't
even log in because there's no
electricity so he apologizes for that
but he's in support we need this and
especially with taking in totality of
the housing and new constructions if the
new constructions for housing
has Energy Efficiency conservation and
renewable more than 40 percent
Pace investment will come in so the pace
investment or Pace will make it
affordable for all income residents if
it is through pace for Energy Efficiency
so that's in a nutshell uh and I can
thank you representative for introducing
this bill
and
I just need you to
we heard a very similar Bill introduced
by yourself last year
and
there was some question about whether
you might personally profit from the
passage of such a bill because of some
real estate Investments or or
companies that you had association with
can you assure us that that's not the
case uh in the in this particular bill
this year I have already disclosed my
I'm I have a consultancy called Shanti
energy consultancy what the consultancy
does is brings these people to our
community and it's not we I'm not the
investing person our company is not the
investor I'm not the thing so I have
dealt with the I've already talked to
Rich Lambert and it uh disclose that and
I've also talked to the clerk and you
know I have if there is a bill very
specifically that
you know this is an enabling Bell so it
is not a bill that would
directly respond to any particular uh
project that's on the dock so that is
and I have it's there's full disclosure
full transparency and this I if I could
just further that saying if I was a
doctor and there was medical bills or
DHHS bills which would help with the
medical field it's the similar situation
so that doctor legislator will not
you know it's not personal gain
good I got it and thank you for clearing
that with uh Rich Lambert and with the
house clerk really appreciate that
so my next question is about
putting a a lien on system benefits
charge funds to further secure energy
project bonds
this is mentioned in the definition of
financing order on page
uh
two I guess line
24 and then it's talked about
extensively on page well now this says
page two
but I guess the first reference was page
one second reference is page two line
29.
I'm having understanding uh problem
understanding how this would work
because the way SBC funds are used by
the New Hampshire saves program
they create triennium Energy Efficiency
plans and each year of the three years
if some of those system benefits charge
funds were
used as a lien on some other
could that and would that disrupt
potentially the triennium Energy
Efficiency budgets and how would the
utilities deal with that problem
thank you for the question uh Mr chair
um
my amendment that I have put forth
addresses some of the thing the biggest
issue you brought up is very relevant
because because of our stack tax
structure in New Hampshire it's very
difficult to establish uh
um lean for private Equity or private
investor if they're investing in Pace so
the way I I'll give you an example I I
hope it'll uh what I've tried to do is
instead of establishing a prime in a
separate fund and lean based on that
fund this is what happened in 2015.
there was a fund and uh Department of
Revenue said you know and last time when
I did Department of Revenue brought that
up and uh
New Hampshire municipals Association
brought it up in terms of uh uh what the
local
municipalities will be holding the ball
and the banker Association also brought
up that you know but they didn't want
another lien based on their mortgage and
stuff so
the reason we need an enabling
legislation that will be addressed if
you look at uh
my um
Amendment what the amendment what I
tried to do was instead of trying to
adjust RSA 53 because if you mention RSA
53e or a the subsection it has a
correlation with other or say you know
there's interaction so in this what I've
tried to do is create a RSA 53f that
doesn't exist
so that way we are starting clean with
so that how it affects the
72e can be you know changed so clean
energy and
um
clean energy New Hampshire
understands where we are and it's a
challenge in New Hampshire to be able to
bring this program because of our tax
structure so what um I will give you an
example this is more like the lean or
the easement situation where in Nashua
there was a property which was Catholic
Charities had or Camp uh the camp do set
where they had leased part of the
property for self cell phone tower and
it's leased for a hundred years there's
an easement and recently a private
developer bought the property but he
brought the bought the property knowing
that that stays that easement stays
because it attached to the property
similarly I want to make sure that this
pace stays with the property
so the lean if if a default happens then
the default is with the property so that
whoever buys the property has this
Improvement which is already invested to
continue with that
does that answer your question or I'm
trying to answer as best as I can
because it's such a huge uh
overarching topic that's why I said I'm
doing a PhD a bridge version of my
thesis presentation
yes I thank you for attempting to answer
the question and while
you may have been only partially
successful there are other people in the
room who might be able to help us out
with some understanding representative
Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so as I understand
that these loans are to be uh
issued by the state the treasurer
that's what your your bill says uh
section 413 loans and finance agreements
the state treasurer shall make loans to
or enter into financing agreements
directly blah blah blah blah blah why
can't Banks do this why do we need to
have the state treasury that will change
with my Amendment so that is doesn't
exist in I try to that's why I'm trying
to make this more and enabling at the
state level than uh you know and you're
absolutely right if it is a mortgage or
Bank the interest rate is much higher
and so if it is Pace investment it's a
private Equity private investor and it
is not uh they need some kind of an
assurance so that uh it's not
um backed by the federal
um credit FDIC right or
I'm not saying it right so uh the
Federal Credit uh bank backed up so if
the private investors are putting
millions of dollars
and they don't have a way to reclaim it
what is the recourse
and so the state is not that I do
understand that was the last time that's
how I started and because I didn't have
enough time to meet with everybody and
come up with a different bill I needed
to put the one that was last year last
term
follow-up
yes uh so if these projects their
conservation Energy Efficiency
Renewables if they are economically
viable why are the interest rates going
to be so high that they're cost
prohibitive I don't understand that no
because the cut the mortgage interest or
bank loan interest is based on the prime
right so when it was lower
we still you know uh
when the prime rate is lower the
interest rate is lower but this is
Improvement uh funding which is not bank
loan or mortgage loan
who does the loan that it is the private
equity and the pace loan which is the
financing it's a different that's why I
said let me
oh my
trying to get my
okay maybe this will help a little bit
let me see if I can articulate it
pace is a state policy enabled financing
mechanism that allows building owners
and developer to access the capital they
need to make energy related deferred
maintenance upgrades in their existing
buildings so support new construction
costs and make renewable energy
accessible and cost effective
and
this is also it's a public-private
partnership enabled by state law and
financed with private Capital that
finances sustainability Improvement to
um
such as Energy Efficiency water
conservation seismic resiliency and why
for Wi-Fi are hardening so this is a
different
tool of financing tool so to be clear
yeah follow-up follow-up thank you it's
not the state it's not the banks it's
another newly created private entity
that's going to do this financing
it may not be created entity but a newly
enabled access another tool for
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative mangaputi for your
presentation today
okay I've heard a few different things
around the funding sources I I thought I
heard you say at the beginning of the
presentation that you were going to try
and leverage some of the federal funding
that's available
and then when I look at the fiscal note
on the bill that we're looking at today
it says that the funding source they
checked general fund and energy funding
to create conservation project fund and
Pace Reserve fund so it sounds like
originally I don't know if I haven't
reviewed the amendment that there would
be two funds that would be created but
it appears that there's State funding
here so
um can you speak to that a little bit
yeah I'll try thanks state fund yes if
it was Reggie funds for conservation or
you know if that doesn't exist it
doesn't exist so what we have right now
is the federal funding millions of
dollars coming to different states for
example I'll give you uh One Fund EV
charging
fund 17 million dollars as a federal
funding how do we access that
that's the infrastructure
right so similarly
um you know if there's a way to access
this
the pace financers investors and capital
investors need to see some kind of
enabling legislation at the state level
to say we welcome you
and so unless there's a mention of this
kind of enabling legislation no
investors are coming so yes in the this
was the old bill that in a previous bill
so if you look at I have tried to narrow
it down to just make it an enabling from
the state level and uh local community
municipalities can adjust it in
fit you know create a program for
example Roanoke Virginia has Virginia
state of Virginia has solarized renew
sustainable renewable energy program
legislation and Roanoke uh Virginia the
city implemented their own RS Charter to
say how the homeowners low-income middle
income High income whoever wanted to
upgrade can Avail if the state funding
is not available at least they can Avail
the federal funding that's available
so it becomes a conduit to help thank
you yeah that's clear thank you
you need a follow-up
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in
um so I I want to make sure I I
understand this correctly this is an
enabling legislation it would not create
a
Statewide fund
um I I come from Hampton so what this
would allow Hampton to do if Hampton's
felt they wanted to is they could create
Hampton could create its own fund for
projects in Hampton that fund would be
funded by any investors or potentially
Federal money that might be available
and then loans from that fund would be
made to projects in the town
and then it would be and then the the
loan would be repaid using a property
tax assessment
yes so let me uh fix some of the and
you're on the right path okay so as I
understand or I'm trying to explain to
you what I understand is if Hampton if
State of New Hampshire has this enabling
legislation they can have a PACE program
that suits their prop uh community so if
Hampton uh comes up with a
program-based program the residents off
uh you know they can borrow against this
uh Pace financing and distribute their
um
loan across 20 over 20 years so it makes
it cost it's not cost for uh
um and especially with that 30 percent
uh tax credit from the federal
government for clean energy now they can
capture that with currently and use it
and so if for example if I put uh you
know I have a five uh complex or I have
a business that I want to put 100
kilowatt solar and do the Energy
Efficiency and all that and I borrow it
and I sell my property it's on the
property I'm not taking with it right
now as it exists you know the buyer
might say take off the solar panels
so you know it's not a portable it's
fitted with the property so that's does
that explain to you yeah quick quick
follow-up
follow-up thank you very much
um so the the the special
the the the voluntary property tax
assessment
um is that a additional assessment on
that property
or is that some portion of the current
property tax that's allocated towards
repaying the loan it depends on the
community right so if I make an
improvement or addition in my home I
have to go to the building permit and so
the you know value of my property might
go up because of the enhanced
Improvement
and especially in the pace what it is
enhanced Improvement
in the tax burden or the tax if it goes
up the benefit of doing this renovation
should be less
uh I mean the tax should not go up
beyond the benefit
so for example if I have a apartment
complex of 10 units if I do the
renovation I do the conservation I can
pass on the uh as a landlord I can pass
on the cost to the tenants but not so
much that the tenants cannot afford it
as it is because of their energy costs
are higher now they're uh you know
additional utility thing that they're
paying so that cost could be rolled into
the
um rent so that they're not paying
additional rent so that balance is very
critical that is what unique about the
pace legislation
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman a quick question
for you on a
this goes back to the uh what you talked
earlier we talked about um it's page six
section two about the treasurer I may
invest money in the fund is provided by
law and we were talking about Investors
earlier and of course and I agree they
need assurances of whether money is
going to what their investment is
um what help me understand what is the
return on investment for those investors
where would that money who does that
money go to and then also or where does
it go to the return on investment of
that and also it means we're talking
about towns here wouldn't each Town need
a separate worn article to be able to
pass anything like this in their town
it thank you for your question and
definitely the idea is to give local
control not government you know the
state saying what to do so what's good
for Nashua may not be good for Hollis
and so uh what is uh you know and in
terms of investors what the investor the
pace investors are asking for is some
kind of a legislation to show this is a
welcome right now we have zero Pace
investors in New Hampshire and uh and
especially with the energy conservation
efficiency renewable and to reduce the
energy costs we need these investors to
come in is and while we are building new
buildings new housing that we need 20
000 plus this kind of Glo goes hand in
hand with trying to look at a total
thing rather than just put putting up
twenty thousand units can we make it
efficient conservation and use these
because they can the builders the
investors can provide that additional
thing to make it
viable cost-effective in for all
not just who could afford but low to
high
okay follow up just a quick question on
that
because I didn't understand I understood
what you're saying about the the
investor what is their return on
investment what do they get for
investing a couple of things one is you
know people that are Net Zero green
developers who want to do the right
thing and build energy sustainable and
reduce the carbon Footprints and let me
see where is that I had like one
specific
line
okay
I have to find my
sorry about it
it is reducing the carbon footprint up
about one kilogram
per
if we go with this effective one so
sorry I apologize I have like hundreds
of papers so I
find it but I will answer that I'm going
to suggest we get the gist of that and
our questions have started to stray into
the territory of the finance committee
Ways and Means
Municipal and County Government
some of whom will all will be looking at
this bill after us so I'm going to
suggest that we
move on since we only have 24 minutes
left in this public hearing
and thank you representative man japoodi
for introducing the bill
and we'd next like to hear from Senator
Deborah alchilder so Senator please come
thank you chairman Vos thank you
committee for your time today so
um
I'm going to backtrack just a little bit
to review what is C Pace commercial
property assessment clean energy c-pace
it's a state policy enabled financing
mechanism that allows building owners
and developers to access the capital
they need to make energy related
deferred maintenance upgrades in their
existing buildings support new
construction costs and make renewable
energy accessible
this c c pace is authorized by state
legislation
requires further authorization from
local governments and is a voluntary
tool for financing Energy Efficiency
renewable energy and resilience upgrades
in commercial buildings more than 37
States and the Washington and the
District of Columbia have adopted sea
Pace enabling legislation because of the
opportunities for investment in local
businesses energy and cost savings and
job creations
this enabling policy opens a door for
communities to transform their energy
consumption making homes and businesses
more efficient and resilient by securing
green energy financing solutions that
help commercial real estate developers
and owners reduce their carbon emissions
and weighted average cost of capital
through a state legislated
public-private partnership known as
commercial property assessed clean
energy sea pace
C pace is a low-cost non-recourse
long-dated self-amortizing product
enabling legislation has been passed in
32 states and the District of Columbia
and as of today 22 of those States and
the District of Columbia have active sea
Pace programs over two billion dollars
in cpace financing has been provided to
over 2 400 commercial buildings the
majority of completed projects fell in
the 75 000 to 750 000 size range though
there are smaller smaller projects and a
couple of large so that's just the the
middle range currently there are 149
Pace programs serving sixty thousand
participants a couple of the advantages
to the cpay structure are they they
provide strong security for investors
because the financing is repaid on the
property tax bill this allows lenders
the ability to offer better interest
rate rates and longer repayment terms
than are otherwise available
additionally assessments are linked to
the property and automatically transfer
to a new owner upon the sale of the
property this transfer has the added
benefit of reducing the risk of default
property owners that voluntarily choose
to participate in a PACE program repay
their Improvement costs over a set time
period which is typically in the 10 to
20 year range although property
assessments which are
uh secured by the property itself and
paid in addition they are paid in
addition to the owner's property tax
bills as the senator from District 24 I
represent the Seacoast that that has
been experiencing increased flooding
from what were once considered historic
weather events but now it seems that
history repeats itself with frequency
one of the ways that house bill 576
could be used on the Seacoast would be
in identifying and mitigating short and
long-term physical climate risks
associated with the street extreme
weather events consistently and cost
effectively at sites across a portfolio
across the Seacoast private Equity
Capital could Propel the project of
creating a centralized checklist to
identify strategies and improvements
when an extreme weather event occurs and
they occur frequently now and further
proper properly utilizing that checklist
to par and partnering with qualified
Consultants to result in a consistent
cost-effective process which would help
protect the occupants and assets from
short to long-term climate risks I urge
the committee to recommend House Bill
576 ought to pass
thank you
okay thank you representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
um there was a mention of low interest
rate loans that are available through
this program what's to keep the interest
that is an excellent question I cannot
answer right now fair enough I will have
to get back to you on that thank you
okay I'm going to permit questions but
they have to be about the energy related
aspects of this program not about the
financing the property tax issues let's
stick strictly to the energy portion
representative Reynolds has a question
um chairman Vos I actually am presenting
in another another bill so I am going to
defer the questions about this project
to representative mangaputi who is um or
representative McWilliams who are ready
great thank you so much and I appreciate
your time today we thank you for being
here Senator we really appreciate it
so representative McWilliams can you
come up and present your testimony on
this bill and because we only have 17
minutes left if you could keep it to say
four minutes would that be fair
absolutely chair Vos no thank you
um
hello fellow committee members for the
record my name is Rebecca McWilliams I
am the representative for South Concord
um
I'm just going to speak to you because
you've already heard all kinds of
interesting things about this bill I'm
going to speak to you on behalf of my
constituents we have a portfolio of
existing buildings in Concord and
developers who absolutely would be
interested in this product
specifically we have a need in Concord
to extend existing natural gas pipelines
and also to do water and sewer
extensions about 50 percent of the city
in terms of land mass does not have
water sewer or natural gas and so these
are energy and infrastructure
Investments that would benefit conquered
tremendously right now we already have a
major pinch with our housing market and
it would be incredibly helpful to be
able to extend these things under Pace
financing to answer the question that
was asked previously the low interest
rate loans are actually at a fixed
interest rate for the life of the loan
so that's how it stays lows it's not a
variable interest rate
in terms of energy related aspects I'm
I'm sure we've already talked about all
kinds of great things like solar and
Energy Efficiency projects that you can
do on an existing building Concord needs
those we need them now and so my
constituents would absolutely benefit
from this product to be able to access
the funding to do that so that's my
testimony happy to answer questions
great thank you for less than four
minutes we appreciate that
representative Reynolds has an energy
related question well yes
um it is because
and it thank you for your your testimony
representative Williams McWilliams um
what I wanted to ask is it is it correct
for people to understand
the value of this pace financing
mechanism
current building owners and developers
who want to make these investments in
the energy
efficiency in the energy consumption of
their buildings
in the Real Estate Management world
folks often don't know how long they're
going to continue to own their building
they might
sell it in five years so they're
reluctant to take a large loan that
would say upgrade the efficiency or
extend the gas pipeline and enable them
to have more efficient Heating
because then they're going to have a big
loan
attached to their company
here yes I'm trying to get to the are we
correct to understand that this is a
a market mechanism to add to the
portfolio of tools in the market to help
those Property Owners access that
financing and therefore decide to make
those Investments thank you for the
question representative Reynolds
um in terms of real estate development
and long-term planning around buildings
both existing and new this is five plus
units we're talking about with this bill
there are there are quite a few existing
ways to finance some conventional Bank
financing private money your own dollars
this is a really popular product in the
28 22 states that do have this this is a
really popular product for developers to
use as an alternative and your question
is correct yes it does run with the
property so if a developer has a five
unit and they decide that they're going
to sell it in two or three years but
they have a 20-year commitment through
Pace that is sold with the property it's
considered a lien on the property so
whoever requires the property continues
paying that bill until it is paid off
that's correct
representative muns do you have an
energy related question
I hope I hope it's energy related
um I was I was very intrigued by uh
Senator all chiller's
um testimony right at the end when she
talked about some of the challenges of
flooding that we have on the Seacoast
and and I was down there this weekend
and there was extensive flooding in the
Hampton Harbor area so my question is
um is the funding available through this
program only for energy related projects
or can it be used as as sen as Senator
seem to imply can it be used for things
like building a sea wall raising
someone's home
that type of thing or is it just energy
that's the energy part
foreign
I'm really sorry that I don't have a
direct answer to that
looks like
energy consumption reduction renewable
energy and gas line extensions have been
approved so it sounds like your question
about increasing Building height to
avoid flooding probably doesn't fall
underneath this however I will tell you
as an architect
that when you're doing that project to
raise the building you're already
redoing the foundation which means
you're probably going to end up doing
some insulation work right so there's a
piece of that project that you could
percentage-wise apply for funding but it
uh representative Wendy Thomas has an
energy question I do have an energy
question thank you much Mr chair
um can you tell me does the CPAP C PACE
program replace current Energy
Efficiency programs is it an either or
or an and can you use both cpace is a
beautiful add-on it allows you to access
funds and you could probably double dip
if you get fancy which is cool that's
okay so you know further questions we
thank representative McWilliams and we
ask rep Mr Michael Licata representing
eversource to
give us his perspective on House Bill
576.
good afternoon uh for the record Michael
Licata representing eversource energy uh
I'll be brief and focused in my comments
um
on behalf of eversource we certainly
believe a well-designed PACE program can
be a powerful tool to help uh finance
and incent Energy Efficiency and
conservation programs with regard to the
legislation before you today and I I
haven't been privy to any Amendment
language
our focus is uh concern about the
references to the system's benefits
charge that chairman Vos had asked a
question about we too are unclear on on
exactly what is intended by the
legislation it appears that the bill
would use the system's benefit charge as
a financial backstop
for these programs
I think there's a couple of issues with
that one the reference to the charge
itself is the actual charge on customer
bills and the bill contemplates a lien
against the charge and I'm not quite
sure
how that would work the uh by way of
background the funding from the charge
is collected by each utilities uh in the
state
held in an account on our each
individual books and then it is used to
fund the Energy Efficiency programs as
approved by the Public Utilities
Commission so even the concept of a lien
against that fund on each utilities
books is I I think
um
just something we're not clear about how
how that would work so you just sort of
have technical challenges on the one
hand and on the other uh there's the
larger policy issue of of whether it's
appropriate to utilize that funding as a
uh as a financial backstop for these uh
for these loans so
um
certainly I'm not uh able to speak to
the details of the rest of the build I'm
sure there are others who can do that
but we do
um
have questions and concerns about the
specific Provisions related to the
systems benefits charge and and I would
note
um you know the the state has received
and will receive
um significant sources of funding from
the federal government under the uh
inflation reduction act potentially one
of those uh funding sources could be
used for for a similar mechanism so uh
I'll stop there and try to answer any
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony and called the last person
scheduled to testify on this bill and
that is Griffin Robards from the
uh thank you members of the committee uh
for the record Griffin Roberts from the
New Hampshire Department of energy I
think our testimony is going to closely
mirror what uh eversources from Michael
cotta's testimony would be the
department acknowledges that there is an
amendment being kicked around right now
but our initial read of the bill as
introduced was to oppose the bill on the
similar grounds that eversource raised
using the system benefits charge as a
backstop for these energy bonds could
potentially threaten the approved
budgets for utilities Energy Efficiency
programs
um obviously as I'm sure this committee
knows uh it has certainly been uh up and
down in terms of the Energy Efficiency
programs in terms in terms of funding
levels the bill as introduced with that
provision in there we feel would add a
very complex and confusing layer on the
management of the New Hampshire saves
programs
um again I fully acknowledge that
there's an amendment based on the
cursory glance of the amendment there is
no reference to the system benefits
charge in that Amendment but the
department would like to review that
Amendment just to be sure that there
aren't any potential unintended
consequences to Energy Efficiency
programs and with that uh closed my
testimony
thank you any questions for Mr robarge
seeing none I thank you for thank you
stopping by to register register your
opposition to the bill as introduced
and I would ask representative closure
to give us a sense of what the blue
for you new members the blue Sheed is
the sheet
that
members of the public members of the
legislature members of the
administration can sign to register
their support
neutrality or opposition to a given bill
can also register their support
neutrality or opposition online and the
blue sheet will reflect those
opinions that have been received
by
morning of the day of the Bill's hearing
people can continue to make their online
preferences known through midnight and
we won't know the the full report until
later but
representative closure will give us a
snapshot on where the bill stands right
now
thank you chair on the house bill 576
there was two in favor
there was one in favor as amended
thank you
uh none on the blue sheet
great and since we forgot to do this for
the previous Bill House Bill 418 do you
uh yes chair House Bill 418 there are
four there is two
in favor Two Against
and
they're all in person okay great thanks
with that we'll close the public hearing
on House Bill 576 and we'll take a four
minute break and then we'll return to
all right I'm going to open the public
hearing on House Bill 92 requiring the
adoption of innovative vehicle emission
standards pursuant to section 177.
of the federal Clean Air Act
and I would like to introduce the prime
sponsor of this legislation
Rebecca McWilliams to introduce the bill
representative McWilliams thank you very
much for the pink card and I'll remind
everyone while she's getting ready that
if you want to speak on this bill I need
to have a pink card from you as soon as
possible
so thank you very much and with that
representative McWilliams the floor is
yours thank you so much chair Bose for
the record representative Rebecca
McWilliams from South Concord member of
this committee pleasure to see you all
again I'll go in three for three today
um I am here to introduce House Bill 92
and I'm hoping to speak as briefly as
possible about House Bill 92 because
there are a lot of people here who have
way more in-depth experience on the
technicalities of this bill than me so
I'm going to put that up front and just
say that the super technical questions
you probably want to save for people
after me I'm going to do my best to
introduce this bill in sort of a whole
cloth broad holistic perspective without
going down the rabbit hole so let's keep
it high level if we can
all right so I'm going to go through the
bill with you
House Bill 92 the intention here is to
implement the California low emission
zero emissions vehicle program so I'm
going to refer to those as levs and zevs
low emissions vehicles and zero
emissions vehicles
this is pursuant to section 177 of the
Clean Air Act which is a federal program
and you may have already heard this
allegory but New Hampshire is a donut
hole compared to the rest of the
Northeast when it comes to implementing
section 177 of the Clean Air Act what
that means is
um
we are behind our neighbors we currently
have automotive dealers here in New
Hampshire
who are not able to get zebs and levs
from the manufacturers that they sell
cars from because the manufacturers are
prioritizing sending those vehicles to
other states that have adopted section
177 so we're lagging behind what does
that mean we're going to have to catch
up
so we had a really great presentation a
little bit ago
to this committee regarding air quality
issues in New Hampshire and we are very
fortunate to be in a position where
right now we're not dealing with major
air quality issues we've overcome a lot
of them but I do want to recall one of
the points that we saw in the
presentation is that the number one
largest contributor to air quality
issues in New Hampshire is Automobiles
and so this is a very real issue and
everything that we do matters when we're
reducing the emissions of the
automobiles that we drive and contribute
to the air that we breathe and the
incidences of asthma and other human
issues with air quality
um so
moving down a little bit on the
introduction of the bill
um
we are proposing with House Bill 92 to
implement the exact standards that are
referenced from the California bill this
has a lot of background information
about the years of vehicles the
emissions of those vehicles and what
that means moving forward for New
Hampshire
specifically the implementation
implementation date of this bill is
January 1st 2024 and it applies to
vehicles with a model year of 2025 and
later so we're picking a date to start
from that date forward we're focusing on
making sure that we can have zevs and
Labs on dealer Lots in New Hampshire
um
in addition there is a credit system
that is set up just like every other
state who's adopted this standard I'm
looking at line 14 page 2 subsection B
this is the credit system regarding how
many vehicles are required per
manufacturer to be sold on Automotive
dealer Lots
and you cannot trade them with other
states or manufacturers you must meet
those requirements for credits in order
to keep stock on your lot to just to
rebut any concerns that people may have
heard from constituents this bill does
not propose to remove combustion engines
from the road in New Hampshire that's
not what we're talking about to be super
clear what this bill does is it allows
and basically creates a standard for
automotive dealers in New Hampshire to
begin receiving zebs and Labs just like
all the other states around us who are
doing this and we're not
um just skimming down a little further
in the bill there is a civil penalty of
three thousand thirty seven thousand
five hundred dollars on a manufacturer
um who tries to sell a vehicle that
fails to meet the emission standards I
know you all remember the Volkswagen
settlement where we've seen
manufacturers in the past attempt to
Parlay something that's not really the
product
and then there's also a penalty not to
exceed five thousand dollars per zero
Mission vehicle credit on a manufacturer
that produces and delivers for sale New
Hampshire fewer zebs or Labs than
required to meet their credit obligation
as part of admitting taking this bill
under
um our New Hampshire rsas
so there is a carrot and a stick in the
spill this is the stick this is the
penalty and I want to note that of the
other states who have adopted this none
of the manufacturers have been fined
with this stick it has not actually been
applied it is simply there to create a
threat to remind everyone that these are
the rules and you need to play by the
rules
moving a little further along in order
to implement this we are going to need
to add a new paid position for someone
to administer this program at the
Department of Environmental Services and
therefore there is a proposal to
increase inspection sticker fees and
division transfer
dollars to make sure that that position
is funded as part of implementing the
program
so the last page describes the position
of overseeing this new
California air emission standards
section 177 bill
so all of that is to say big picture
we're behind we need to catch up one of
the things that I emailed to the
committee and I'm just going to speak to
off of my screen here is where are we
headed as a as a global industry where
where are we going with Automotive
manufacturers and we're in 2023 now so a
lot of these commitments are for 2030
and 2040 we're talking about either
seven years from now or 17 years from
now Automotive manufacturers have made
commitments for where they're going to
be on their vehicles so for example
Volvo 100 of global sales
is to have electric vehicles by 2030. so
in seven years Volvo is going all
electric General Motors also 20 30 100
of global sales going Electric in seven
years BMW Ford Subaru I'm sorry BMW and
Ford are 50 by 2030 so 50 of all
vehicles sold by 2030 will be electric
vehicles and then we get a little bit
lower down which Subaru's 40 Global
sales 2030 Toyota 35 percent Global
sales 2030.
and then some of the other names you
probably would expect to hear on the
list Honda is going to do a hundred
percent of global sales by 2040. so
they've given themselves 17 years to
ramp up to all electric and finally
Volkswagen group once again 2040 100 of
global sales so this kind of gives you a
snapshot of where the market is and
where it's headed
and I do also want to mention uh I
discussed the stick right the potential
penalty for manufacturers there is also
a carrot for folks in New Hampshire who
would like to purchase a zevolev off of
a New Hampshire lot if and when New
Hampshire decides to adopt this standard
it comes along with a eight year eighty
thousand mile warranty that protects any
defects with the functioning electric
components in the vehicle so that
wouldn't be you know a problem with the
bumper per se but it could be a problem
with battery or performance range issues
eight years eighty thousand miles so
this gives another layer of something
good for our people our constituents by
adopting this bill
so with that I will open it up to please
broad questions only I'm happy to do my
thank you
um representative McWilliams for
introducing this bill I have a couple of
quick questions just to
help us with context is this the same
bill that you introduced on this subject
last year or are there substantive
changes there are minor changes in
regards to dates of implementation and
the the vehicle ages so 20 25 Vehicles
obviously is a change yes okay great
thanks representative Thomas has a
question Doug Thomas that is thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I I think it's the question
given your background you might be able
to answer uh on this
um
on my copy of the bill
between lines five and eight it talks
about the uh that the uh the regulations
May incorporate by reference to
California motor vehicle emissions
standards set forth and finally
regulations blah blah blah but it says
uh and uh
and as may be amended from time to time
if this bill was adopted uh does this
mean that New Hampshire would be tied to
the California the California law and
any
um change or amendment that the
California law does that we would that
we must follow along with any amendments
that they make with that
I see where you're going with that
question representative Doug Thomas
um as you can imagine this program has
been around for a really long time
California pioneered it over 10 years
ago and so there have been updates to
California law in order to address
targeted percentage goals year over year
and also update the the year of the
vehicles that are being impacted
so there have been changes and I
anticipate there will be more changes in
the future and so yes the fundamental
answer to your question is we would have
to be tying it to that statute under the
language as written in this bill thank
you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative McWilliams I'm looking on
page two and it's section two line 25
when it talks about the stick imposing a
civil penalty not to exceed five
thousand dollars per zero emission
vehicle credit and so it says credit on
a manufacturer that produces and
delivers for sale in New Hampshire fewer
zevs uh and and I'm assuming it means
leves even though it says zebs or zevs
then required to meet at Zev credit
obligation when it says fewer than is
there an actual designated amount of
vehicles that a manufacturer has to have
on their lot in order to meet it I know
you said that this isn't a penalty
that's generally imposed but I'm just
curious if there's an actual number
okay let's get technical so credits
means that a zero emissions vehicle gets
let's just say to keep the math simple
let's just say it's a three credit
vehicle whereas a low emissions vehicle
could be a one credit vehicle so there
is a credit requirement for the
manufacturer to deliver to that dealer
but it could be met with multiple
combinations of vehicles on the lot so
it is a little bit more complicated than
just saying you need to deliver X number
of cars
okay thank you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
looking at this question it was enticed
by it because of the the adoption of the
California low emissions or emissions so
actually and originally I thought it
well we just had to worry about until
2035 when it went to 100 all electrical
vehicles but then when I pulled up the
California code regulation the Levin's
up to have a copy of it I noticed here
that on the percentages that it if I
understand correctly that by the end of
next year if it did go in the Implement
we'd have to have 25 percent of all
vehicles in the state would have to be
um electric 35 the following year and
goes up nine percent every year until
2035 which is 100 so does that mean are
we is it substantial to be able to reach
25 electric vehicles the entire state by
the end of next year
so I want to be super clear that the
things that this legislation addresses
are the vehicles on dealer Lots not the
actual makeup of the state
Vehicles driven right I mean everybody
in New Hampshire is going to be driving
whatever year their car is currently
until they go to a dealer and purchase a
new vehicle so when we're talking about
percentage commitments we're talking
about percentage commitments for dealers
to provide not necessarily forcing
people to purchase
follow-up
follow-up so the requirements if we
adopt the California law here that
states that the percentage of each of
electrical vehicles within the state
needs to meet these certain matters of
25 percent and go up to 100 percent only
sold in 2035. is that not what we'd be
adopting as well
so I'm sorry I don't have exactly the
chapter and verse in front of me that
you're quoting from but I'm happy to
chat with you afterwards on this I think
this is really Technical and we may have
some folks who can speak better to it
representative Munds as a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative could you could you
reconcile
um the references to the federal Clean
Air Act in the bill with the question
and the answer that you the question
from representative Thomas and the
answer that you gave isn't there a
connection between the California
representative I'm not sure I understand
your question I I had I I thought I had
heard or read somewhere that the
California standard has been
incorporated into the federal Clean Air
Act
or is that not true that is true okay so
so it's really not a California law it's
a federal law correct
so the way that this bill is written it
still references California Section
1961.2
so we would need to revise the bill to
address the federal standard that's
matching that
okay
representative barajny has a question
thank you chairman on here there's 10
states listed as having adopted the Lev
Zev standard that all 10 of these states
adopt uh pretty much the same language
referring to the California code thank
you
um yes the answer is yes thank you for
the question
representative lewicki has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um on the eight year warranty does that
include the battery it's a two-part
question
would the would the warranty include the
battery
I believe so but I will probably be
corrected if I tell you the wrong thing
by someone after me I believe that is
true and the second part of it is then
would the manufacturers not build the
cost of a battery replacement into each
uh electric vehicle sold and that would
increase the prices by whatever amount
that might be
foreign
so I can't speak to how manufacturers
set their pricing or how they determine
what they do for a warranty program
unfortunately I don't have enough
information on how Ford creates their
pricing or what their idea is for
something under a warranty in a zeber
love state but we may have someone here
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
you stated that a major goal of this
bill would be to increase
um New Hampshire residents access to
electric vehicles and low emission
vehicles on dealers Lots our our New
Hampshire dealers losing out currently
when New Hampshire folks go shopping for
a car and they can't find one on New
Hampshire lots are they crossing the
lines to Maine Vermont Massachusetts and
buying their electric cars
there
great question
um there's
there's the anecdotal data which you
just described there are certainly
people who simply go out of state
because they want to test drive and
drive something off of a lot and there
are also very large dealers in New
Hampshire who are able to still get zevs
and loves because they may have a
location somewhere out of state and
bring one onto a New Hampshire lot
so it's a rather nuanced situation
because it depends on the size of the
dealership and their access to Vehicles
as well as inventory right it's all
about inventory so if we have the
hottest newest Ford Model that just
comes out in January that everybody
wants to buy it's going to be very
difficult even for a dealer who is cross
state lines to bring one into a New
Hampshire lot because it may be so hot
elsewhere and they need to meet the
credit requirement elsewhere that
they're trying to sell it to to keep
that met so to answer your question I
think we have seen that it is an issue
with behavior of car buyers and
certainly access to zevs and loves in
New Hampshire is limited because we
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
actually two questions one is the table
that you sent us about EV sales I just
want to verify that these are about
electric vehicle sales and not
electrified vehicle sales I know for
example Toyota has been advertising they
have electrified vehicles but they don't
currently sell a single EV
thank you for the question uh once again
I did attach the article to back up the
data that I was reading out loud so you
can actually go through and see exactly
where Toyota falls on this
what we're seeing is low emissions Lev
would be the Toyota zero emissions would
be something like Tesla
okay and and if I may ask the second
follow-up yeah thank you
um about the fee for inspection stickers
I actually received an email from
someone complaining about the increased
fee for inspection stickers so uh as I
understand it it's a change of 50 cents
per sticker now are these are these
stickers these are issued to the
inspectors
who then may or may not pass that cost
um I'm not sure the answer to this
question on how we handle the finances I
can tell you as someone who gets my car
inspected every year there is a there's
a line item for the inspection sticker
fee but then I get service charges and
additional stuff on the bill so I don't
entirely know how that's structured in
terms of the 50 cents due does get I
think it actually says in the bill
exactly how it's structured for passing
it on 50 Cents gets passed on for DS to
hire someone
but the actual cost of the sticker I
just don't know enough about how we do
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh so when you
introduced the bill you said one of the
key drivers was lowering emissions uh
and so we wanted trans you want to
transfer us over to uh levs and zero
emission vehicles uh but that
electricity is made by
uh
well in New Hampshire largely
um
uh natural gas so how have we really
changed the net emission profile have
you have you studied what's happening
there
so I have some really exciting news for
you representative Bernardi
these zebs and Labs mostly the zephs
have batteries and we are now just
entering the ERA this is exciting right
for the engineering science Geeks in the
room we're now just entering into the
era of being able to charge back to the
grid
so when you have a let's just say it's a
Zev parked in your garage
and you hook it up you can actually be
putting the battery back in the grid to
reduce your electric bill
and then when it's a lower rate time you
can be drawing from the grid to recharge
the battery so this is something that
the co-op is pioneering it's super
exciting and we're just at the cusp of
it so when you talk about what our grid
is made up of yes fundamentally we are
both nuclear and natural gas in New
Hampshire
but moving forward as we increase our
Renewables and as we look at
alternatives for how we diversify our
energy sources in New Hampshire we're
able to keep it in New Hampshire in the
battery in your vehicle
and then put it back in the grid to help
your neighbor out which is super
exciting
follow-up
so right now natural gas nuclear are the
means of producing electricity so if we
you have to charge that battery with
electrical power so it's coming from
either Seabrook station or natural gas
facilities or bow when it's running or
whatever with coal so you're powering
that battery and that car with
fossil fuels how is that changing the
net emission standards or what's the net
Delta
so this is a long
a long lead bill this is Forward
Thinking we're talking about setting
this up so seven years from now when
we've achieved those goals that the
manufacturers are listing or 17 years
from now when the longer lead
manufacturers have achieved their goals
and I have a lot of Hope
that New Hampshire will be able to do
this and will increase the Renewables in
our grid
then we're going to have more diversity
and we're going to be able to use the
batteries and we're going to be able to
pull but you're right for today
all of that is just long-term planning
but we have to start somewhere so that's
what this is it sets up a plan
I have some additional information about
a question earlier
California was given a waiver under the
clear Clean Air Act the federal
that's the
answer to a question I think
Representatives Summers had
are there any representative Reynolds
has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um representative McWilliams is it isn't
the correct answer to representative
Bernardi's question that
the fact that yes all electricity
we're charging electric vehicles comes
from the grid but as we were told by the
utilities and the iso just last week
less than half of the Grid electricity
comes from natural gas and oil combined
and 23 plus 16 plus 6 percent comes from
nuclear and hydro and 10 Renewables and
16 Imports which is mostly Quebec Hydro
so isn't the grid much cleaner
so we're comparing apples to oranges
thank you representative Reynolds when
we talk about New Hampshire's energy
versus the big bucket that is ISO New
England obviously we're part of iso New
England so unless we act like Texas and
create our own special grid we're going
to have to and in a good way we're going
to be sharing multiple different kinds
of energy so thank you for the question
representative Reynolds and yes there
are many other contributors to our mix
in New Hampshire because we're part of
iso New England but two representative
Bernardi's question I think we do need
to look at diversifying our mix
specifically in New Hampshire because we
do want to have the ability to charge an
electric vehicle off of local homegrown
renewable energy right wherever it's
representative pleasure has a question
uh thank you chair uh thank you Michael
Williams representative
um
or questions if I read this right
the first one is there other any other
companies New Hampshire that we
so we regulate things that need to be
regulated this is the energy industry
which is a monopoly that requires
regulation and guard rails we also
regulate pharmaceutical industry we have
certain things that you can't sell right
now I know there's a bill being heard
tomorrow related to cannabis so we have
regulations as the government because we
decide to step in and set guardrails
around specific items
a follow-up to follow up thank you um
and I'm going to add two together
the question is is this going to
increase the size of government and add
more fees in a inflationary period thank
you
this is going to increase the size of
government and add additional fees
that's your question
correct
well the bill does add a position and 50
cents so the simple answer is yes the
okay see no further questions for
representative McWilliams I'll next call
on Mike Fitzgerald from New Hampshire
Des who wants to um
elaborate on a couple of the issues
good afternoon Mr chair Mike Fitzgerald
assistant director of the air division
Department of Environmental Services our
department takes no position on the bill
um I do want to uh uh provide a little a
little bit of context on a couple of
issues that have been raised
um first just for clarity the uh as uh
cheerivos indicated the federal Clean
Air Act does provide that California can
establish its own vehicle emission
standards and that in order to do so
they must achieve a must receive a
waiver from the EPA uh each time they do
that that has been that has happened
numerous times over the past 20 years
California has established this low
Mission vehicle program and it has been
consistently provided a waiver what
section 177 of the Clean Air Act does is
it allows other states to adopt
California's regulations but section 177
is extremely clear that there are two
choices
Federal standards or California
standards no state may adopt any
standard that is some hybrid where you
pick and choose some part of California
standards or whatever you adopt
California standards as they are or you
adopt or you just live with the federal
standards you cannot the the general
interpretation of that is you cannot
write a bill or or adopt something in
legislation that would have the effect
of creating a third car a third vehicle
there's either California vehicles or
federally certified Vehicles currently
California and the federal federal
vehicle program are harmonized through
the year 2025.
um I believe in EPA intends probably to
extend to extend that some period after
2025 the federal standards California
has indicated a that they they would
deviate that was an agreement between
California and the and the federal
program several years ago that they
would harmonize those standards and so
through 2025 those would be um those
standards would be the same after that
it would depend on what California does
this bill does indicate prospective
adoption of California standards that
would be consistent with the Clean Air
Act requirement because if we were to
adopt the California standards as of
today and then they changed them next
year
then for that period that would create a
third vehicle essentially and so we
would be prohibited from doing that we
would need we would need to be
harmonized one way or another
um uh the technical issue that I want to
point out just very quickly is that um
the uh section 177 and the Clean Air Act
does require a four-year lead time
um I I also want to apologize uh Becky
ohler who many of you met last week
she's our expert on this uh this
situation she's also in in Dover without
power today and that could not be here
so I apologize up front I'm not the
technical expert but
um we certainly can get answers to to
questions that I that I don't know of
which there may be many but
um the the dates in here are not
implementable first of all it would be
impossible for us to adopt rules in the
time frame that's allotted here
um General rulemaking from we would need
to start commence rulemaking we couldn't
commence that rulemaking until after
this bill passed and and was signed into
law by the governor until effective date
of the bill and then it takes us
approximate only one year to go through
the rule adoption process so that they
we could not meet and then I'm again I'm
not certain on this issue there's some
there's some question whether it's two
years or four years and perhaps the auto
dealers who are here may have a little
bit more information but I uh the the
Clean Air Act does specify the number of
years of model year lead time that that
it must be given before implementing
these requirements so that would be an
issue that we would need to take a look
at and resolve
so
um
the bill does uh have a fee the question
was asked about the source of that fee
that fee is currently three dollars and
25 cents that's a fee that you pay when
you have your vehicle inspected for the
onboard diagnostics portion of your uh
your inspection and uh that fee
currently is three dollars and 25 cents
we received 25 cents of that fee to work
on programs to reduce emissions from
Vehicles this bill would change that fee
to 375 and allocate an additional 50
cents to the department again to create
a position to administer this there has
to be someone to check to make sure the
vehicle manufacturers they submit all
their reports and and someone would need
to audit those and go through them and
determine whether whether the standards
were being met and those standards are
met by supplying certain Vehicles the
issue with regards to supply of vehicles
again that's one that the dealers can
probably speak to better than I but I
would just mention
um there there is
since the other states that have adopted
California Lev
the left does create certain
requirements for certain amounts certain
percentages of vehicles to be sold and
so states that have adopted the
California standards must meet those
percentages as well and so therefore the
dealers
the manufacturers May
preferentially Supply certain vehicles
to other states that have adopted these
vehicles that that we have not so they
may they may just say well there's only
X supply of
model
b470 and we therefore are going to
allocate allocate them to Connecticut
because New Hampshire doesn't have the
requirement in place but as to whether
that creates particular shortages or not
I can't speak to one issue that
representative Bernardi brought up I
would I would just simply address also
that the
uh electric vehicles are inherently more
efficient and in their use of energy so
therefore
whereas a fossil fuel powered vehicle is
on the order of 20 to 30 percent
efficient in converting that fossil fuel
it's close it's very very significantly
higher double maybe even triple in some
cases in terms of the efficiency of the
electricity that's used so even though
the electricity may have come from the
same Source less energy is required to
convert that energy into the wheels
turning on the ground so there is a a
benefit even today to that
uh to that situation uh I think
um that pretty much concludes my uh
um
concerns and I'd be happy to try to
address any questions again
um we can produce mazola for
um a work session or whatever or provide
to other information
following this hearing
thank you Mr Fitzgerald representative
Doug Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question this is just a clarification
I I may have misheard what you said you
said that the federal standards and the
California standards are the same
currently
did you mean to imply that New Hampshire
is currently under those standards yes
because the federal has standards
Federal as a state either follows the
federal standards or they may adopt the
California standards those are the only
two choices and so the federal standards
are in effect in New Hampshire
and they're both the same they're both
the same through 2025.
um okay that's fine gratification thank
you uh representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman I'm
wondering if you're able to compare the
emissions uh the tailpipe emissions for
uh uh a conventional vehicle an internal
combustion vehicle let's say per gallon
of fuel burn compared with at a power
plant per gallon gallon of fuel burned
uh how do they compare well again it
depends on the power plant and as was
mentioned the grid power that comes here
when you plug into the
electricity here you don't know whether
that electron came from Connecticut or
from Seabrook or wherever but
um so grid electricity if you look at
ISO New England they provide an average
overall emissions factor for for their
electricity by and large my
understanding here is in in New England
is that the uh a significant amount of
our electricity is is from natural gas
but as was pointed out by representative
Reynolds there as uh certainly nuclear
non-emitting and
um and other Renewables but if you apply
that grid average
um that would be the average emissions
from from the grid and power plants are
generally significantly more efficient
Motor Vehicles it's a motor vehicle is a
small power plant but inherently it's
somewhat less efficient so in general
motor vehicles fossil fuel powered motor
vehicles are less efficient and have
greater emissions than electric vehicles
even when you consider the electricity
in which the vehicle was
was supported but it's it's a complex
answer
um to what should be an easy question my
apologies
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh to go off of uh
representative Bernardi's question
earlier and we talked about the
efficiency and where electric vehicles
in the long run will be more efficient
is it not true that it takes about 17
metric tons of CO2 to be in the
production of a each individual electric
car when it comes to lithium and Cobalt
I couldn't speak to that specifically I
wouldn't I I would not question there
there certainly are emissions there are
missions associated with production of
any any vehicle whether they're greater
or lesser in the production of EVS I
certainly can't
uh speak to that directly
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and just to clarify
um
so if we took all the vehicles on the
road today and converted them to
electric vehicles our net emission rates
would go down today
correct okay thank you
representative lewicki has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering about
the person who isn't here is if people
are not you know we've had three days of
Storms and uh the people who drive
electric vehicles may not be represented
here because they can't charge them is
that correct
I
I can't say I would imagine there are
some people who have have some
difficulty I live here in Concord and
had some difficulty getting here so uh
uh I would not dispute your question
representative Reynolds has a question
well I just want to say that I have an
electric car and I drove here today no
problem
can you drive home all right
representative partial has a question
yes thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh would you consider that the uh miles
per gallon equivalent that some cars
advertise to be a good rule of thumb as
an example I'm hoping to take possession
of a Nissan Leaf in the near future and
they told me that it gets the equivalent
of 115 miles per gallon sure so that
tells me that is more better efficient
in line with what you're saying yes yes
um I again I'm not sure how that's
calculated EPA and the manufacturers
have a fairly complex algorithm for
determining vehicle fuel efficiency but
by and large electric vehicles because
they use less fuel we'll use less energy
to produce the same output generally
have a higher mileage efficiencies and
that that mile per gallon equivalent
would be calculated based on the amount
of BTUs in a gallon of gasoline versus
the amount of BTUs in the grid average
in follow-up
follow-up but just remember we're not
here to speculate on the value of a
electric car versus a non-electric car
we're here to talk about whether we
should adopt California's emission
standards
and I will defer them
okay thank you
any further questions
seeing none we thank you Mr Fitzgerald
for elucidating several issues and I
called to the stand now
Mr Lawrence Arts of Nashua who is
dude my name is
please turn on the microphone
thank you
for the record my name is Lawrence Arts
from Nashua
I am heavily opposed
to house bill 92.
of this bill an act requiring the
adoption of the Innovative vehicle
emission standards
this bill sets us dangerous precedent it
essentially hands over legislative and
Rule making Authority directly to
unelected bureaucrats of the State of
California air resources board which is
carb
and perhaps even
to the California bureau of auto repair
which is the Babar California bar and
gives them broad authority to set
California style air quality policy for
the State of New Hampshire
by a few
if any of these members without ties or
knowledge of New Hampshire it's people
or its culture this bill hamstrings New
Hampshire to automatically Implement
four Cent effect of these vehicles
New Hampshire is not California
our climate does not lend itself well to
outright internal combustion
vehicle bands which this bill will
ultimately Target it may work in
Southern California with this year-round
warm weather no snow and perfect roads
but not here
we have our own issues with Motor
Vehicles unheard of in California like
cold Winters salted roads and rust
this bill will impact New Hampshire
residents in a negative way suppose a
New Hampshire resident travels to the
Carolinas Georgia Florida
and they get into an accident and then
they destroy their vehicle they will be
prohibited from buying a new vehicle in
those states to replace their destroyed
one simply because it is brand new and
only meets the federal emission
standards and not California standards
in addition they may also be denied the
ability to inherit acquire in a divorce
Southern lint lawsuit a gift Etc or even
be able to buy the vehicle they find
that they really like it and be able to
register it in New Hampshire unless it's
a California vehicle
this may mean the only way to obtain an
out-of-state vehicle they will have to
settle for an older perhaps a more
polluting vehicle as an alternative
these emissions restrictions going back
to the early 1980s a greatly
disincentivized me from owning a new
model vehicle the Nashua area tailpipe
emissions law passed in 1985 was the
deciding factor for me to keep and
refurbish my 1972 Volkswagen Super
Beetle a car with that predates
catalytic converters and just made the
age to be exempt from that upcoming law
into which I started driving in 1980. I
remember as if it was yesterday it was
October of 1984. my Volkswagen was the
need work as rust started to take hold
of it and then I read about how the EPA
was about to jam tailpipes emissions
inspection testing programs down our
throats only for those that live in the
Nashville area with a threat by the EPA
to withhold Federal Highway money
all based on one day of air quality
carbon monoxide violations at one
intersection in downtown Nashua that
occurred in March of 1978 which at the
time only three model years worth of
catalytic converter equipped Vehicles
were in existence as they were
introduced along with unleaded gasoline
beginning in 1975.
it was at that time I made the decision
to spend a couple of grand and totally
rebuild that Volkswagen so that I can
keep it on the road and not have to deal
with this then new emissions testing
Fiasco which they started to stated was
to begin in the fall October of 1987.
back then they said the vehicle will
either be 15 years old or heavier than 8
000 pounds it would be exempt well the
VW was to be 15 years old in 1987 and
its registration was renewed before the
Law's effective date
so I started body and body and
mechanical parts for it and I made that
72 Volkswagen into a new car again to
this very day I still own that vehicle
and it is still operational
and it is now approaching a quarter
million miles on it as the odometer
rolled back to zero twice in the
following years
that law along with the threat of
enhancing the law in the 1990s after the
Clean Air Act of 1990 was passed and the
politicians were gearing up to force all
the old cars off the road they strive to
expand this centralized enhanced
emissions test law to include the 1968
model year
which led me to focus exclusively on
only buying and driving pre-emission
control air vehicles meaning pre-1968 so
I bought a 1966 Chevy 2 Nova and two
more pre-1968 station wagons a 1963
Chevy 2 Nova station wagon and a 1967
Chevy 2 Nova that I got out of a uh got
out of a junkyard down in Massachusetts
back in 1992.
and then I started hoarding Parts out of
these for these vehicles out to allow
their operation for many more decades as
I cleaned out junkyards out of their
Chevy two parts in New Hampshire and
Massachusetts
fortunately massive public outcry and
pressure from the
Den pressure from then Governor Stephen
Merrill and the outcome of the massive
Democratic defeat in 1990 in the 1994
midterm elections led to the New
Hampshire legislature to abandon their
efforts to go after the 1968 to pre-1975
pre-catalytic era vehicle owners because
the federal law somehow prohibited going
after cars manufactured before 1968
because they pre-existed clean air loss
and a huge scale down of their owner is
centralized emissions testing Empire
plants which the state was to contract a
company called Enviro test a huge
emission testing Empire at the time to
implement California style smog check
in 1995.
to this day the newest vehicle I own is
a 1992 bottle a Chevy Silverado long bed
that I acquired for my father with low
miles an extremely solid Body and Frame
I made a special level effort to heavily
rust proof for the underside of the body
panels with an annual application of a
full gallon of fluid film rust proof and
linole and oil to prolong its operating
life
to near indefinite time I have been
spraying that truck for many many years
now I do it in October each year because
that vehicle is now 31 years of age it
is absolutely solid with zero rust
anywhere and I have absolutely no plans
to replace that truck with anything
newer since number one the truck is one
of the last Model years to use the
pre-obd2 and Ultra reliable throttle
body fuel injection system because
problems on the GM trucks plagued 1996
in newer trucks with that with the
spider injection that they were forced
to implement can I ask you to kind of
refocus on the California emissions
rather than giving us a history of
vehicle ownership sure sure sure
um
yeah if if this state implements
California emission requirements we are
going to have to do everything that
California does including implementing
their very onerous California style smog
check not only out in California do they
check for OBD2
but they also do a complete
comprehensive thorough underhood visual
inspection
on on these vehicles
and they do a tailpipe test you got to
put it they'll put the they'll strap the
car down on a dynamometer they'll run
the thing at highway speeds and they
measure the amount of exhaust so
a smog check out in California is like a
couple of hundred dollars to do compared
to uh just plugging in the OBD and
that's what that's what what happened if
we went full California
also and this is what they did back in
the 70s they were requiring uh Vehicles
all going back to the 1955 model year to
to retrofit them with these aftermarket
uh
uh closed PCV systems and then they put
in what was called the California car
kit program car kit kit
for a 1966 to 1970 1970 Vehicles which
basically disabled the vehicle's vacuum
advance and they required that you have
to have the manual
for that car kit retrofit in the glove
box you had to have a label on the under
hood of the car and you had to have a
sticker on the dashboard that says do
not drive that car greater than 60 miles
an hour or engine damage will result
this is what they implemented in the
1970s they did some really crazy stuff
for emissions and and I tell you
California is very hostile to to older
vehicle owners I always talk the story
about a
friend of mine know how to Rolls-Royce
out there in California because of their
uh standards they required him to
to put these added emission stuff on it
for that the car I don't know where it
came from England or something like that
the car passed emissions before all that
stuff was put on it
when they forced him to spend a thousand
dollars to retrofit the car they they
had him they had them put a vacuum line
from the fuel tank into the carburetor
and the car would just run horrible and
then it the emissions was even worse and
I and I hear that story over and over
and over again from this uh friend of
mine that uh that knows this guy the
guy's passed away right today but uh
this is a bad Bill and uh
I urge in expedient to legislate on this
legislation well thank you for your
testimony do you have any idea what
California does
for all those old cars that you see in
Hollywood movies uh how do they keep
those on the road well they they further
amended the law that now they go and
smog check model year 1976 and newer
cars they they ultimate they used to
just keep it fixed at model year 1966
and then they had their own special uh
emission control devices 66 and 67 model
cars had smog pumps on it where the 49
states cars didn't have
um
some of these cars are really tough to
to get past emissions I remember the
Volkswagen peoples they they used to the
Volkswagen Club there used to keep it
guys would have an engine and they would
share it with the club members here put
this in your Volkswagen because they
were so easy to Interchange out on those
to get your to get your car smogged
and then go back to putting the uh
Factory uh or your other engine into it
because they're cooled engines they used
to be a real problem to try to get
through smog check representative Doug
Thomas has a question sure thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um do you feel that if we adopt the
California standards that it would
severely limit your choice of
what vehicle to purchase and or modify
to meet your needs as a as a consumer
yes it would because California plans to
out ban outright
internal combustion engines by the year
2035 and so I would have no choice but
to keep older internal combustion engine
vehicles running because I like to be
able to have a vehicle if I want to
drive to Florida
I want to be able to get down there in
two days I don't have to take a weekend
have to stop and charge 100 every 150
200 miles and spend you know how many
hours it takes to charge a vehicle so
we'll follow up thank you with follow-up
Mr chair so furthermore do you feel that
if this is adopted then it would affect
your lifestyle uh as a consumer uh in
terms of how you want to live your life
in terms of your choices and so forth
well I would simply just keep my
existing older vehicles running it'll be
like you know I think that a lot and a
lot of other folks you know I always
talk about the cube in effect how where
Cuban restricted uh Cuba restricted uh
newer vehicles and they just kept their
older ones running and running and
running and I'm afraid that if they're
going to make it so costly and so
inconvenient with these newer vehicles
with these restrictions that people are
just going to keep all the cars running
into perpetuity
representative lewicki has a question
yes okay thank you Mr chairman and thank
you you woke us up and that's what I'm
trying to do get you guys going uh the
question it may not be something that's
within your knowledge base but does it
uh I'm going to put it two questions
does this legislature have the ability
to bind a future legislature if we were
for instance to pass this law if two
years from now another legislature
repealed it uh could we possibly do that
and how can we possibly be bound by a
California legislature
um
I don't know whether or not once you
pass it you know how when you pass a law
it's very difficult to repeal it because
it gets entrenched into it but uh I'm
afraid that once you once you pass this
law you're you're you're obligated to uh
follow California law from here on out
and uh whatever they pass has automatic
effect here I mean that's
like like on buying a vehicle from
what I what I would say I used to always
say when you're exporting a car from the
United States of America and importing
it into California they used to they
back in those days they used to penalize
these people by charging a 300 smog
impact fee to and and the car had to
have more than 7 500 miles on it or be
more than two years old and it was a
real nightmare to try to get a 49 state
car registered in California and uh
representative uh Nutter also has a
question
thank you since you pre-answered my
question on Rust
on the old cars my first question for
you is what do you call it when a
government the government steps in and
takes over a business and tells them how
to run it and what they can sell like
Cuba I don't know I think that's called
communism
and my second question hang on before
you ask your second question what is
we're supposed to be discussing the bill
good point you have a question about the
bill representative in related to the
bill
um I wanted do you know anything about
the 17 States suing the EPA for letting
California set vehicle standards
um I vaguely know something about I
haven't read deeply into it but I'm sure
that there are
states that are uh they're you know
having clean air lawsuits and stuff like
that I know when a few years ago
when Trump was in office they um he
tried to get the relaxed the auto
emission standards relaxed and I think
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you gave an example
earlier about uh someone's driving down
south and they have to replace their
vehicle in North Carolina
and I'm just wondering how would a New
Hampshire law that limits the number of
non-uh Zev LED vehicles
affect what one would buy in North
Carolina okay this is what happens in
California you're not allowed to buy a
federal a new a California resident is
prohibited from buying a
brand new federal vehicle
it has to unless that vehicle has more
than 7 500 miles on the odometer or is
more than two years old so if a New
Hampshire resident
has gone on a trip wrecks their vehicle
and wants to buy a replacement
that person because if it's a federal
vehicle they'll they will be prohibited
from registering it in New Hampshire
because that's what the California
law mandates and that was that's the
same uh deal with Massachusetts here
back I remember back um
this is a going back 10 15 years now uh
Guy where I work down in Massachusetts
he wanted to buy a turbo diesel uh
Jetta a brand new one but they passed
the California standards and they were
not legal to sell in Massachusetts and
he couldn't buy one in New Hampshire
unless it had more than 7 500 miles on
it
to register it for the first time in
Massachusetts so well without instead of
going through all that red tape he ended
up buying a 1988 Jetta and said the hell
with it
representative Kaplan has a question
that's taken my question Mr chair
um I just want to say as a former owner
of a bug owner I commend you for your
for your uh
Devotion to those older cars because I I
also agree that it was fun to work on
those cars you know and uh it's getting
harder and harder to work on cars as
things get more computerized more and
more regulations but um as a as an older
car owner you must work hard to get
those cars past their their uh their
inspections every year uh so my question
is to make sure that would you be in
favor of going back to those you know
pre-smog regulation days when it was a
lot easier to keep cars on the road or
have you gotten used to those new
standards and I would suggest maybe you
could just do the same with the with the
stricter air emission standards in the
future or do you you know or do you
favor going back to no standards
whatsoever
I'd say we go back to and make it a
simple cheap affordable car like
Volkswagen originally had but no the
federal government has mandated OBD2 and
all these complex things that they they
basically legislated a simple car out of
existence you can't you can't you can't
get an affordable car anymore if you
look at the price of cars as a result
you know
it's becoming more and more Out Of Reach
for the average person the cost for them
and uh you know that's that that's a
reason why the vehicle
age the average age of cars are just
increasing over time I mean what is it
11 12 years now it used to be
you know five six years old
so you know and then and I see in the
future as cars get more expensive
that age Gap it's just you know the mean
age of cars are just going to get older
and older
okay saying no more questions we
appreciate your testimony okay thank you
you did uh stir us up we appreciate that
hey you know I gotta wake you up you
know okay next I'm at a call on Mr
William Hall from Durham
who is representing himself and who
thank you chairman Voss
uh
I started to read this
the other day and I came to uh how it
was going to kill people and make people
sick
uh back before the emissions business
started uh Pasadena it looked like the
smog looked like fog coming through in
the noon by noon time New Jersey was
pretty bad
the intersection of Mass Avenue and the
Mass Pike in Boston
didn't look bad
but technically by the standards it was
we've corrected all that with catalytic
converters and other uh efforts to to
make uh the to clean up the emissions
since a country is going to be rapidly
changing over to electric cars according
to the electric car people uh this
problem is going to go away you look you
fly over to Hampshire it's carpeted in
green
you fly down south of one of 495 128 and
it's carpeted with roads and cars and
you can see the traffic lights as far as
you can see that's not the case in New
Hampshire at all
um
the next thing I saw here was what it's
going to do to the roads and bridges the
um uh greenhouse gases no what bothers
the roads and bridges is road salt and
hundred thousand pound uh trucks that
would be carrying uh eleven to thirteen
thousand pound uh gallons of gasoline or
heating oil uh that's what destroys uh
roads and bridges uh I don't believe the
uh emissions would have any effect on
them whatsoever uh in the period of time
between it wouldn't extend uh shorten
the life between uh repaving one bit
um
as far as electric cars go uh we better
have a new attitude towards generation
because this fall
uh California was telling people not to
not to charge their cars as you know
Germany tried to go for renewable energy
and it's now changed back to Coal until
they can get that under control I don't
want to see us making those mistakes and
I don't want to see us subjected to the
measures of California I don't think
it's
worth the effort I think it's going to
just be a mess for people this is a
small state we don't compared to the
amount of space we have we don't have a
lot of cars you only got a little over a
million cars
thank you
thank you for your testimony questions
seeing none I thank you for your
testimony and next I call on Dan Bennett
representing the New Hampshire Auto
welcome Mr Bennett good afternoon Mr
chairman members of committee Dan
Bennett New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association my testimony will be
relatively unchanged from some of the
things you've heard from us on this
particular issue in the past few years
I will bounce around a little bit
between testimony but also address some
of the questions that I've heard from
the committee as well so as we have in
the past it's our opinion that that this
bill is a topic worth study and we
believe a study commission should be
created to explore it may include
Department of Environmental Services
nescom the office of energy the auto
dealers the manufacturers to all look at
it I appreciate and I heard the sponsor
mention a plan but this isn't a New
Hampshire plan this is a California plan
so let's get together and create a New
Hampshire plan and and see what works so
that's our opinion we hope as we have
stated multiple times over the past few
years
um a bill last one a bill last session
and two prior uh to study it
um so to address some of the points New
Hampshire dealers are all in on electric
vehicles they're building out their
facilities they're gearing up for it we
have four dealers rural Ford dealers in
the North Country spending 1.2 million
dollars of their own money to build out
a charging infrastructure
okay other manufacturers are encouraging
as well stellantis General Motors
so
um the the dealers are all all in on it
but it's based on consumer demand
and and they will sell it to people that
want it uh it's not a state law or a
mandate that that's going to drive that
consumer demand it's it's the consumer
demand and and our neighbors all do have
um you know higher EV rates than us and
they do have that particular mandate but
I don't believe it's the Mandate that
sells cars it's the other things they
put in place every single state has a
cash incentive on the hood of the
vehicle to move it they have charging
infrastructure built out a great much
greater rate than New Hampshire does
they have time of rate charging to
encourage you to charge your vehicle
overnight so you're not pulling from the
grid when it's at high demand and high
cost those are some of the things we
suggest that the commission look at
um incentives
that's what moves the market a carrot
not a stick we've seen it in the past
everybody remember Cash for Clunkers
no during the Obama Administration New
Hampshire had the highest take rate per
capita in the nation in Cash for
Clunkers and there was one hood on the
people the hood of the car people raced
for it and they traded over those
Vehicles so that's really something to
explore another issue that I'll mention
about the the the Lev standard or the
Zev standard
um you know it's our opinion that the
calculation's all wrong
because the calculation is not done at
the at the sale or when the vehicle is
put in service the goal is emission
reduction correct so that calculation
should be done when it's on the road the
calculation is done when it's delivered
to the Dealer's lot
so when the car comes in and it just
sits there
and it doesn't sell there's no emission
reductions really being done right so
the calculation it's in our opinion is a
little skewed if the penalties do in
fact come into place that then raises
the cost of the vehicle which further
makes it less likely to get put into
place so let's look at ways to get the
cars on the road
so that's some of the things that we
should look at
um
that's when the true emission reductions
would come into place
um you know New Hampshire dealers will
sell EVS to anyone that that wants them
they'll meet that consumer demand I've
spoken to BMW I've spoken to Ford the
individual in charge of the the mock e
the E program for Ford the state law
doesn't matter to them they'll sell the
cars where the consumer demand is
the inventory shortage or those
anecdotes that I've heard is is not
about choosing a cal live State over
another state it's that the
manufacturers are not making enough cars
there are no islands of mock e Mustangs
in in Norwood Massachusetts
the cars are built and made to order you
go to the dealership site unseen and
order that vehicle because the
manufacturers are making so few
you know Cadillac made 25 000 lyrics
last year they sold out in somewhere
between four and six hours
because of they're making so few of them
um you know Ford I give a lot of credit
to Ford you know you can go to any Ford
dealer right now and you can get in an
electric lightning F-150 pickup truck
because they require you to keep one in
stock and it's called a mannequin model
so you can put your you can sit in that
seat and you can demo the vehicle and
then you place an order and wait for it
to come
but it's the reason they've adjusted
their production models four times
already to increase those numbers
because they've seen the demand so it's
a manufacturing issue it's not a state
law issue in our opinion and we've
spoken to folks about it
um
so
you know and then just the other thing
miss Mr Fitzgerald mentioned that the
difficulty with the dates the carb
standard does ban all ice engine sales
in 2035.
um backed that out based on the numbers
that's in about nine years uh that we
would be at that end of sale of internal
combustion engine
um I don't necessarily know if that's
what all of the public wants
um or some of it um and now I'll just
kind of Bounce Around to some of the the
stuff that I heard that the questions
penalties haven't been issued we heard
and that's true but that's because the
quota rates are are significantly low
right now and there's also something in
the marketplace where manufacturers who
make EVS can sell the credits and that's
exactly what they do
Tesla sells all those credits to those
gas guzzling manufacturing companies and
so that's how they meet that quota so
there's a little bit of a game being
played with with the purchase credits
and things like that so that's why no
penalties have been issued to
manufacturers yet but as we get into
that range where those percentages start
to ramp up those penalties could I guess
potentially come into play again the
penalty structure is is something that
we should look at
um and that's why we're willing and we'd
welcome and we've supported having the
discussion further to come up with that
New Hampshire model
the bill raises the sticker price by 50
Cents on an annual safety inspection
um the the math on that came down to
last year
um
1.5
million safety inspections times another
50 cents that's 770 000 raised for one
state employee
and then where does the rest of the
money go
we would certainly say if this was the
pro the bill the legislation that moved
forward that excess funding should be
used in a vehicle purchase incentive
program because that's what's going to
change the market that's what's going to
move it and then one other point that I
just do want to make there's some
um for you or
uh whomever the work group to look at is
there's a
there's an interesting section in in uh
section 21A that says nothing in this
section shall limit the commissioner's
authority to regulate more vehicle
emissions for any other class of vehicle
so in my mind I start to think about
snowmobile ATV construction farm
equipment
um heavy truck
um that's a that's a pretty broad range
there
um so I guess
um
and see if there's any other questions
again we've seen in our neighbors
neighboring states that incentives
really help the system
um so without anything like that I think
would be set up for failure if we did
implement it so that's why our
suggestion again is to get the get the
like-minded folks together uh have a
healthy discussion look at what could
really grow EVS in the marketplace in
New Hampshire and get us to that end-all
goal maybe the the California law isn't
the way to do it but maybe there's some
really other innovative ways that we can
achieve that emission reduction and also
get those EVS out on the street in
driveways and garages
um
so with that being said
um I'll attempt to take or answer any
questions if I can
representative Kaplan would you turn off
your mic please
representative Thomas has a question
Doug Thomas that is thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I've
been waiting this time to ask this
question to the dealership Association
um
if this
bill was adopted or even one that you
suggested under a study say
would it
as opposed to now would it limit the
number of normal vehicles uh
availability to someone who would want
to buy them later on in other words
would there be less of the normal
Vehicles available for individuals to
order as opposed to the new EVS
so thank you representative I'll attempt
to answer the question as best
um and clear as I can that's really up
to the manufacturer it's what they
choose to develop in their product
Pipeline and you heard of some of the
manufacturers who are getting rid of
internal combustion engines there are
others that aren't so in that period
over those years both vehicles could
essentially be sold but it is true that
in the the carb standard the Cal Zev
standard that was adopted this past June
it says after the end of 2035 no new
vehicle sales that have an internal
combustion engine will be sold in that
state
so we will reach a point
uh 12 short years from now where you if
this law was adopted a consumer would
not be able to buy a new gas engine
vehicle thank you
okay representative Nutter has a
question
thank you this is regarding charging
stations since you mentioned those I
like they have some in front of Whole
Foods in Bedford who pays for the charge
I mean I see cars go in and they plug in
but but how does it work it's not like a
gas station the vehicle owner pays for
that charge there's a system of
operating system some of them are tied
to an app called chargepoint is one of
them for example you use you have an
account you know for Teslas like you see
on the interstate those are same things
paid for through an account that you
either have through the manufacturer or
a third-party charging app so Whole
Foods isn't giving that energy away for
free they've chosen to make that
infrastructure investment and then the
consumer in fact pays for the charges
for their vehicle thank you
representative Summers asked a question
thank you Mr chairman
um this actually has to deal with the
same question about what dealerships and
my question is is the majority of it's
basically demand and risk right risk and
demand um with most of the dealerships
in New Hampshire being classified
according to California standards
intermediate volume manufactured dealers
so and phone under that
do you find that when you talk to
dealerships and you deal with
dealerships that they're willing to take
the risk of having by the end of next
year I've been 25 percent of their
inventory on the lot being electrical
Vehicles whether it's gonna if the
demand's there
I think what dealers would say is they'd
want to see the demand there it's a it
is you're correct and that it is a big
risk and they believe in the product and
when you do vehicle ride and drives with
electric vehicles the conquest rate is
really high
um it's it's a they're very they're
great vehicles to drive
um but if you look at our current
registration rates that's a big jump to
get from where we are to 25 percent
right thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming in
the um the bill says that New Hampshire
consumers cannot benefit from the
eight-year 80 000 mile extended warranty
provisions of the California standards
unless we adopt them can you talk about
the warranty provisions
yeah uh briefly California in adopting
this law adds an additional uh warranty
you know guarantee related to the
electric drivetrain of the vehicle if
you in fact adopt this law because they
understand they've the law has
prescribed a higher number of electric
vehicle essentially quota in the state
so
um it benefits the consumer
um and I guess uh if that work did come
in it would help a service station as
well
however uh you know this isn't Brakes
and Tires
what breaks down on vehicles are brakes
tires hoses body rust tail lights brake
lights it's not the transmission the
battery components that are in the
engine you know when the Prius first
came out people were were scared
what are we going to do with this 7 000
pound battery and it's not going to last
the battery replacement rate on on
Priuses that was projected is certainly
not come true
um you know and and manufacturers spend
a lot of money on R D for their product
sometimes they they reach you know an
unfortunate scenarios like Chevy did
with the bolt that had those battery
fires and they had to pull them back
but other times there's been Priuses and
leafs that are on the road for 10 years
running now Problem free
follow-up
um if a if a if a vehicle that has been
um that's that's certified for
California emissions
well I guess it's a two-part question
can vehicles that are certified for
California emissions be sold in New
Hampshire and if that's the case
um is there a difference in the warranty
provision the warranty coverage
so thank you for the question yeah
vehicles that are that meet the the Zev
rating are are available for sale in
California and New Hampshire
um uh now does that mean that they are
no I mean no one buys the Toyota Mirai
in New Hampshire because it's a
hydrogen-powered car
there's nowhere to fuel the vehicle so
um you know that's an example of where
the vehicle would really not make its
way
make its way into the state but then
with that vehicle
when if and when something happened
here's how it would work is and I think
I hope this answers your question if and
when there was a problem with the drive
chain of the vehicle and the vehicle was
purchased and registered here in New
Hampshire you would only have the
specific warranty if that same thing
happened or that same problem happened
and it was a Massachusetts customer the
Massachusetts customer would have that
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um you said earlier in your testimony
that you thought there might be
confusion if we went ahead and adopted
the California emissions standards but
um the testimony that we heard earlier
was that currently the only two
standards that are available are either
the California emission standards or the
federal standards and my understanding
is that all of the other states
surrounding Us in New England have
already adopted the California emission
standards so can you talk about why you
why you testified that it would be
confusing because it seems like the
other states are not they don't appear
to be confused so
yeah yeah uh thank you representative
I'll do my my best to to answer your
question however I don't remember a
point in my testimony where I talked
about confusion
I'm confusion amongst the two standards
there's only I mean I think when I spoke
about there's two standards is it a cal
so may I respond to clarifying yes
please yeah I think what I'm referring
to is you had testified that you thought
that if we went to this you characterize
it as a mandate and you said you thought
that it would it would make the
dealerships position confusing I thought
uh I respectfully I don't remember
stating that the dealerships would be
cause confusion
um
so I apologize I'm not sure I'm
following
and if you'd like to talk after I'm
certainly open to that as well sure I
think you were referring to the
California standards when you said you
thought that it would be it would create
confusion here in the market in the auto
market here
um and I guess
other dealers in other states have
already had to adopt this and it hasn't
really created Market confusion I don't
believe so that's I guess what I wanted
you to speak to remember uh
representative we don't engage in
all right representative uh Reynolds has
a question
thanks Mr chairman I guess I'd like to
repeat the question that I asked you're
probably the one best position to answer
it since all the other states in New
England have adopted California's
standards and therefore
presumably have plenty of
Lev and Zev vehicles on their Lots
here in New Hampshire our dealers may
have that one
as you've called it mannequin model our
New Hampshire dealers losing out on
sales right now to out-of-state dealers
for these vehicles for which you've said
they're pretty
would you call it a high Conquest rate
once people drive one they like it if
they want to buy one are they going
south or going north and buying one from
an out of state dealer
so do out-of-state sales happen yes they
happen for all types of vehicles gas or
no matter what the powertrain is and
it's based on on vehicle
availability and inventory and inventory
over the past few years actually has
been a struggle no matter what the
vehicle is
now are there
islands of uh Toyota RAV primes in
Lowell but none in Nashua uh it's been
referred to but it's anecdotal and it's
it's not in fact true I can guarantee
there is a dealer in every corner of
every community of the state if you walk
into that dealer and tell them you want
a particular vehicle they will work very
very hard to ensure that they get you
that vehicle they'll do a trade with
another dealer I'm sorry I don't have
the EV that you want but I've got a
really nice Silverado that the guy next
door does and so they'll swap they'll do
a dealer trade and they'll do their best
to sell you that vehicle but also keep
you as a customer right that's the key
to success is making the customer happy
so they will work on your behalf for
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you very much Mr chair
um
you testified that dealers want to see
the demand before the before creating
the supply of electric cars that they
felt uncomfortable not knowing what the
demand was but wouldn't an adequate
supply of electric cars create the
demand
so
well no because just if you have a
parking lot full of cars but if the
customers aren't interested in that
product then those that product will
move the concern is the quota if the
manufacturers built enough of the cars
anybody who wanted one could get one
regardless of what the state law is so
if the consumer's demand is there
because of the purchase price the
affordability the ease of charging the
ease of travel and the manufacturer
builds enough of them then essentially
the product should sell itself and the
state shouldn't Force the product to be
sold follow-up
follow-up or delivered
are you seeing
for electric cars going up
yeah the demand is growing can it grow
faster it certainly could through the
ways that I mentioned that we've seen
all of our neighboring states who have
higher registrations do and it's not
because of state law it's because of
policies like mentioned about time of
use charging in cash on the hood
incentive purchase prices to lower the
vehicle costs uh just the comfortability
of seeing Chargers hanging on the wall
at the rest stop and hooks it you know
makes it seem like it's more of an
availability so they're willing to take
that leap remember this is a new
emerging technology that some folks
aren't used to so there has to be a
comfortability factor to ease them into
the market and with that that consumer
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so as things stand
currently
if a dealer in New Hampshire and let's
say it's a dealer that doesn't have
locations outside of the state wanted a
certain allocation of EVS would they be
able to get the same allocation as a
dealer in a state that follows the
California law
dealers have the same availability to
order product
but it depends on how much product
exists now are there dealers that buy in
larger volumes
certainly you know dealers own their own
inventory the manufacturer doesn't pay
for that
the dealers do that's their alone what's
called a floor plan you you borrow money
from a bank to afford your inventory so
they're gonna put they're gonna take
that loan and put into their inventory
product that they know is going to move
so that they'll be able to pay off that
loan
you don't want a product to sit 60 you
know 90 days you want to you want to
move that so the dealer has the ability
to order that from the manufacturer so
whether they want to based on the
consumer demand and whether the
manufacturer is willing to be able to
follow up
so I just want to be clear is your
answer yes yes they have the ability to
order product they certainly do and and
and the product would be delivered If
the product is available you can go down
to the Ford dealer and put your name for
a Maki right now
you can go ahead and order that vehicle
and you will get it it may be three six
nine months
but that's because they're not building
representative closure has a question
yes thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question
um not knowing the
sales or the admissions like we're
looking at here for the other Butters
States would you know if this line in
this bill
92 is what the other states
apply it's on the page two line three
I'll read it for you such regulations
shall be applicable to new motor
vehicles sold in the state of
whatever
after January 1st 24th the question is
it's being implied that other states
have this our Butters so in 24 and after
can they buy in a car vehicle in New
Hampshire not compliant with their state
and registered in the state the
registration is the key question can
they register yeah so thank thank you
representative
um you know unfortunately I don't know
what other states policies as far as
limiting registration is uh I know in
the past uh under a pre a different
version of this law you know when
Vermont uh when there weren't 50 state
cars which was what there are right now
there were vehicles that New Hampshire
dealers could sell that other states
could not a diesel Jeep Liberty is one
example and you could not cross the
river uh purchase the car then go back
into Vermont to registrate to register
it but I think that depends on
individual states what I do know is
correct is what was mentioned before is
um you know you either adopt the
California standard and you're all in or
you adopt a federal standard there's no
kind of state-specific provision where
we'll say we'll take this chunk of it
but we won't take the ice the internal
combustion engine ban you can't chop it
up you can only take it's all or nothing
really
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question
um I'm not going to ask the question
about what happens when the incentives
are taken away from EVS if the man will
go down or not because that's not part
of this bill what is part of the bill
though my question is if this date were
to adopt this bill
uh by say in by by 2035 and including
the states around here as well
does that mean that individuals
wouldn't wouldn't no longer be able to
purchase a new car vehicle that is not
EV and therefore if they didn't want any
V would they be forced to purchase a
truck or some other vehicle that isn't
covered by this bill
so
I'll I'll take it in two parts thanks
for not asking the incentive program
question
because then I don't have to use the
example of Georgia who dropped their
incentive program in EV registrations
dropped off 80 percent
what I will say is after 2035 the the
bill will state because they're adopted
the California standard that no internal
combustion engine Vehicles will be sold
no new internal combustion engine
Vehicles will be sold so if someone
didn't want that they would be forced
okay seeing no more uh questions I want
to thank you for your
testimony here this afternoon thank you
very much we look forward to the
discussion and we sincerely do hope
um because we do believe in the EV and
the product and that that this committee
make the decision to form a study
commission to see how we can further it
so thank you thank you
and now we'll call on our last
um
I'm gonna try real ravage
okay she represents the New Hampshire
motorcyclists rights organization and
she opposes this bill thank you so good
job Tracy borvage
I am the president of New Hampshire
motorcycle rights organization
we would like actually clarification in
New Hampshire motorcyclists are
considered a motor vehicle
we went through this and we could not
find in the California legislation
where we are either included or excluded
in their particular legislation so the
first thing we would like to know is if
we are included or excluded in the
California legislation
having said that
if we are included
we are definitely opposed
for several reasons first being we are
very involved in this state there are
over 80 000 registered motorcycle riders
in New Hampshire which is pretty
significant for a little state
and I represent them all from Racers to
dirt bike riders we have a lot of EV
riders in our organization
we like them all doesn't matter what you
ride spiders doesn't matter we walk on
the mall
we believe in freedom of choice of what
you ride we don't think that someone
should tell you that you should have an
electric motorcycle
or an internal combustion engine
motorcycle because we believe that
everybody should ride their own ride and
what they ride they should choose
we also have worked very closely with
the Automobile Dealers Association many
times on lots of different things and we
work with a lot of Manufacturers and we
do not feel that they're going to be
able to deliver
enough of the what is required in the
California legislation to be able to
meet writers needs by 2035 or as they go
down or go up every year if Riders
choose to buy electric motorcycles
we also think and I don't know if any of
you are writers motorcycles do not have
the range mileage range that other
vehicles have
and with what we're seeing for
infrastructure with the charging
stations motorcycles are going to have a
really really hard time
going very far besides their maybe
neighborhood or backyard and trying to
charge our motorcycles they go about 130
miles
in one tank
130 150.
so with what's being put in place with
infrastructure with charging stations
uh I can probably go to my local store
or maybe down the road a couple places
whatever but we're not going to be able
to go like other vehicles with the
charging stations and I don't think the
government's going to want to put
charging stations in place just for
motorcycles
and like I said with 80 000 registered
motorcyclists in New Hampshire
does New Hampshire want to put charging
stations in for all of us because you
can bet we're going to come back here
and want charging stations for the 80
000 of us that ride
having said that thank you respectfully
for allowing me to speak chairman Vos
and members and I will be glad to take
questions I'm not sure what I can answer
for you but I'll be glad to take
questions
well you could try to answer one for me
if you like please and thank you thank
you for being here today and speaking
with us
do you have any experience at all with
electric motorcycles what is the size of
a battery that would go into an electric
motorcycle and what would its range be
I've only been a one to see what it felt
like I do not know the size of the
battery I know that I know that that
particular
size of the motorcycle is bigger than
like someone my size would want to ride
I can't reach I can't touch the ground
on the electric current the electric
motorcycles so for me riding one would
not be an option right now
okay thank you
other questions representative Summers
Mr chairman is going to answer your
question right now there's Harley
Davidson only has one model of electric
and it goes about 102 miles
range
oh thank you appreciate that
I like the name right thank you I want
to try to pronounce it Beau Rivage Beau
Rivage
no other questions for Ms Beau Rivage
so I guess we're done thank you very
much so I'll ask representative closure
at this point to tell us what the blue
sheet uh numbers were for this bill
please
uh thank you chair could I also later
review the other two bills I have the
online
yes you can do that later okay for this
bill House Bill 92
the blue sheet was one in favor
or against
the online was 35 in favor 11 against
we're going to go back to house bill 418
the blue sheet was too in favor
Two Against
House Bill 576
a blue sheet was three in favor
one in favor amended
on line 34 in favor one against thank
you chair
okay thank you very much
all right so I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 92.
and that for the most part concludes our
business for today
I do want to alert anyone who is
watching the live stream of this
committee session
that the executive session scheduled for
4 P.M this afternoon has been canceled
the reason for that cancellation we have
not heard the bills that were scheduled
for executive session they were supposed
to have been heard yesterday but due to
the weather
this building was closed and
that meeting was canceled so those bills
were not heard they will be rescheduled
in the calendar
many of them if not all of them will be
scheduled for next week
or the Monday following because
five of the bills that we will have
heard
by the end of next week will be early
bills that need to be processed
as quickly as possible because they have
to go to a second committee
so we will be having uh
executive sessions on those bills next
week to remind the members we'll meet
Monday Tuesday and Friday next week
and of course there's a house session
next Thursday so
uh sadly we'll have to drag you all up
here to Concord four times next week but
we have to get our our business done so
um we just
do what the weather demands of us and uh
meet more often next week Mr chairman
question yes representative McGee do we
uh have any intention of executing on
Monday or Tuesday so we can prepare for
that if yes there will be an exec
session on Monday none on Tuesday and
another one on Friday okay so these
bills we heard today since it's the only
bills we've heard right on Monday
I can't promise you that it's the exact
bills we heard today but
um
bills that we heard
today
next Monday
next Tuesday will be some of them will
be exact on Friday and on Monday will be
bills that we heard today okay thank you
okay
anything else
I thank you all for being here great